I mean six Oh Down Goes the Queen on d1
rook G 321 Howie Howie oh my gosh you
know what dobro just did brushed its
shoulder off that was awesome Wow and we
are back live and with Grand Master
Robert Hess IRL at the 2019 speed chess
championship Grand Master Robert Hess
how excited are you to see the top seed
the man the number one overall player at
car Nakamura start his campaign to
defend his crown this year I'm so
excited to actually tweet it you know
how you know what a rare occasion that
is for me it is it is well I tweeted
that you know we had a great breakfast
this morning we did especially
considering that it took me a long time
to cut up those raspberries
they are perfect they were perfect yeah
and we'll get into social media a little
bit of course later today as we dive
into all things hashtag speech s but
let's remind everybody of the bracket of
how we got here who's still standing
who's not obviously Yantra stuff Duda
gave us a thriller the last time we were
alive barely getting by onigiri yawn
upon me ah she has moved on as well as
Maxine Bosh a graph so the car Nakamura
looks to join that group today obviously
he is the very very heavy favorite let's
remind everybody of the format that he
is the favorite in and has been known as
one of the best players on the planet
for years we've been doing this SEC
thing for a while but it's 90 minutes of
five-minute 60 minutes of three-minute
and 30 minutes of one minute Robert I'm
gonna ask you what of those time
controls do you think Dobrev has the
best chance in wow I'm not allowed to
say none of the above
I'm gonna go with the 3+1 blitz segment
because I think the 5 minute the more
time when the clock generally the better
it is for the high rated player ok I
think that yes hikaru is going to
dominate all three segments of this
format but I do think the three one
format is probably most likely for Dover
to score some points he's the most used
to that at planks three-minute time
control so I think that's where he
should try to score his most amount of
points well we'll see if that prediction
holds true the term on ebay what they're
playing for of course we got a lot of
cash from
homey $16,000 in the first round and the
prices get bigger with every single
match up from here on out speaking of
the match up let's move right into our
smarter chess predictions obviously as
we know hit Karnataka more the number
one seed favored in all time controls
appropriately than not the 95%
probability Yonder pom neon she's got
nothing on that he doesn't and if you
look and you know how I like to argue
with smarter chess yep look at the 3-1
score
that's where doe ROVs game most of his
points according to smarter chest look
at you you are you aligning with an
analytics it's like I'm in a multiverse
something something weird so well with
that let's let's keep rolling here
remind everybody of the Power Rankings
of course the overall ranking for Hikaru
Nakamura has him as one of the best
players in this format of all time and
with with that I don't really know what
else to add to that right obviously
Dobrev knows he has his work cut out for
him he qualified it's kind of like
qualifying to get into March Madness for
some of the 16 seeds just being there is
awesome of course I know he's not
showing up today for a moral victory
he's showing up for the for the free
jokes the free dad jokes he can't listen
to that he can't listen to you right but
he watches it on replay so and with that
let's let's get ready to jump right in
we have both players here they are ready
seated hit Cara Nakamura in his position
that many have come to know him well you
can follow her car of course on his
channel twitch.tv slash GM Hikaru and
Dobrev also a streamer yep in Russian
for those who don't know so these guys
play regularly on chest comm they scream
regularly and the games are about to
begin here for them to throw down
regularly for the rest of the day and
with that we have action yeah and we see
that a car with the white piece is
facing to rough Sicilian of course
inspired by Magnus versus Fabiano
Caruana well this line has just been all
the bee's knees really since November
2018 since the last time you and I were
sitting next to each other but most the
time when I try to reach through the
green screen my hand disappears at this
time all right
well we've got um we've got a quick
position into a bind here huh so we've
got a miracie bind structure holding
back d5 and b5 for those of you who
speak pawn structures in the Sicilian
hick are Nakamura off to a pretty good
start here as white so what are the
difficulties black faces here right
you've got a lack of development you
also have to watch out already for
tactics like Knight to d5 with the rook
spying the Queen these positions what
can we what can we offer here from an
instructive standpoint for black I guess
the main thing to highlight is black
structure is always very solid so as
long as you don't run into tactical
problems usually you have long term
chances but I'm gonna guess a Caro knows
what to do here you can also be
aggressive Queen d2 and have four ideas
here and a very important thing to note
it with your idea of 95 is that the pawn
is on d7 and not on d6 so that you know
if Y had chosen ago Knight d5 and once
the Queen moved off the C file just need
to show that right so does he take on d5
first right C takes the move Queen to d8
after D takes c6 I take with the D pawn
and now it's not so bad for black guys
my bhishma have six looks good and I
don't have to compromise pawn structure
you see right as you highlighted the
pawn not being on d6 at core Nakamura on
cue plays c5 which really pokes at that
fact they're targeting the d6 square and
this is often the structural issue for
black here especially as kind of a
heads-up play right like hey your
opponent changes footwork here relocates
a bishop and you immediately take
advantage of the fact that it has left
the square c5
so c5 is a really nice move actually
rook d8 and now with the trade you're
gonna have this permanent problem on the
dark squares look for something like
Knight a for to come for hit Cara pretty
quickly yeah and this 9 g6 just not
nearly as good as the knight on c3
because the knight is trying to go to b6
and more importantly the bishop on c8
it's not doing too much at some point
black will try to put a 5 and open up
the diagonal for the bishop but as soon
as you play e5 look at your bishop on f6
right yeah now looking so good not gonna
be your favorite piece chewing on grain
up there Plus this move Bishop c4 by
Hikaru kind of heads-up in the sense
that you put a bishop on but will become
a newly opened diagonal he completes my
blank before I can even say it right and
here comes Knight a4 heading into b6 but
look for Bishop e6 I guess here from yo
bro and I think okay I guess the
question is can Bishop e6 be met by some
like Bishop takes up for it or miss oh
so after Bishop takes c4 I mean he was
in Queen you know exactly what you're
showing the structure is just not as
good for black as you would like the
double pawns and that's kind of what's
happening on the board not quite there
should be six at karo plays Knight b6
first and takes the knight out and
immediately then decides to kick Knight
that's gonna force a trade on c4 cuz you
don't you don't really want the double D
pawns here unless you decide you can get
away with a little check do a little
dance make a little check come down
tonight yeah I get down tonight but your
might your knight might end up getting
trapped tonight on h3 if you're not
careful right so makes me think that
we're gonna see Bishop takes c4 here
first what if he tries Bishop h3 can
like his position doesn't look very good
so if we talk in a practical manner is
ya good for black to just try to go
all-in and say I'm gonna sacrifice my
knight on f4 and you know just try to
get your king open probably I like it
let's look at it right Bishop II I mean
I like it but you know they're not my
pieces as you know so I'm gonna
sacrifice away takes takes both the rook
and the bishop are currently hanging I
mean I instinctively I have to doubt
that this is good for black but as I
look at it it looks a little tricky as
Queen e5 comes next if you if you go
Bishop d2
there goes Queen e5 and doesn't look so
easy
yeah the King just really feels wide
open on g1 no no minor pieces there to
protect it so Dobrev is sitting and
thinking right now but I imagine the
bishop h3 is the movies really
considering we see her Cara Nakamura
active in the chat talking about picking
up some donuts in between moves so uh I
don't know maybe we should get him a
pizza or something if he's hungry well
if you know if he takes on f4 in some of
those lines he might start offing the
donut in this time okay what
Vlad's gonna give him the opportunity he
plays Bishop h3 inviting these sharp
lines very good pride and Hikaru
approved of it cuz I saw how he
responded with you know facially yeah
that's pretty interesting
yeah and then now he's sitting in there
and contemplating we see here current
outcome or our stats coming at you live
holds the record for the largest ever
margin of victory I think Magnus
Carlson's victory over took on Petrosian
and one of the first years was actually
maybe second but again don't quote me
I'm not here to be some
we've got okay so he moves the rook but
here comes Bishop g4 so Dobrev not given
up on the idea that this night might be
poisoned if you take it and I think
again you called it from a practical
perspective how do you so obviously the
storyline here is gonna be the Cardinal
more as a heavy favor right and we'll
get into the daily question here in a
minute which actually asks you the fans
who you who you think actually has the
best chance of an underdog I wonder how
many votes Dobrev gets but regardless of
that I think that how do you pull upsets
against much stronger players you have
to play with no fear right and you have
to be willing to mix it up you can't
play and expecting them to outplay you
right you gotta put pressure on them and
hope that maybe they're all formed that
day right because while hey Carlos class
is permanent his form
you know sometimes sometimes can be
often that would be what Dobrev is
hoping for yeah so I mean I like the way
he's played this let me - I think dorbz
actually is a very good position now
especially relative to where we were
before and I see Ali Riza firoozeh in
the chat so that's another speech Chess
Championship contestant there but look
that Bishop on I have three we're
talking about how bad it wasn't c8 just
for move five moves ago
yeah or many was and now the bishops on
f3 it's very advanced and what you take
on d4 just you can choose to look tasty
for looks good put the next one on d8
and there's certain look much much
better for black than I did earlier yeah
agreed and if you get the other rook
here all of a sudden one of the things
that's risky about outpost squares on
the side of the board for everyone
versus the center of the board is that
if play becomes all about let's say the
center or even the king side that the
the piece that you've out posted on sort
of the wrong side of the board is pretty
to look at but not very useful right so
that's kind of what's happening here and
so Dobrev gets credit for creating the
counter play he has with the bishop here
and the D file because it leaves this
knight feeling a little bit sort of out
of sorts right not not the most
effective piece despite that it visually
is on a very good square and it's why
Hikaru keeps trying to offer the
exchange of light squared bishop saying
well yes my knight gets back in the game
but this night that will remain on the
board will outclassed this bishop when
I've six cuz look at that bishop where
is it going right there's no diagonal
for it to work with no target for it to
attack so that would be ideal for a car
which is why I don't always very smart
when your fate when you have these two
bishops right you often want to keep
both of them
the board the advantage of the dark
squared bishop is not just that you have
one it's that you can control both color
complexes when you have bishops of both
colors in the board yeah and the
question is how do you how do you do
that right the so the structure is not
going to be open for this Bishop anytime
soon you maybe would like to go after
the yeah you want well now he offered
the bishop exchange because he said when
you an f3 you've weakened the g3 square
so perhaps he tried to reroute his Queen
over to g7 play for g5 yeah of that
nature but denies very strong here yeah
here it comes to d6 although you know
dobro of keeping options open to deal
with it when it comes there and with a
king being open there's always the
potential of an exchange sack if you're
not you're right so v right now looks I
love g5 right bring it just g5 and you
take take with a bishop and try to play
H for yourself there it is there he goes
and it takes takes and then H for just
try to keep things open and that rook on
d4 Queen d7 combination is trying to go
to d2 if you ever move your knight away
so you can't just start jumping your
knight all over the board yeah you're
absolutely right because ninety six
looks like an annoying threat but as you
point out Bishop g7 can all just take it
out and and again it you wouldn't sack
the exchange obviously on ninety six if
the bishop here is gonna remain blocked
but at some point if you can imagine
diagonal that becomes useful or maybe
some sort of dark square infiltration on
this side you have to watch out here if
you're a karo and give a dobro of credit
given the fact that at one point in this
game Hikaru was up I think closer to two
and a half minutes right now up about
thirty seconds so the the position is
tricky in here goes to karo thinking a
little bit for the first time yeah in
the in the day deep in the think tank
yeah on that move that a new picture on
this wall there looks like Christopher
Robin's about to pop out you are there
any magical forest of we need to poo h4
he's gonna take on g3 and look out for
some fireworks right it's just a certain
good for black yeah he's looking great
for black actually I mean takes put the
bishop on it and then you Brooke
sixty-four ideas to make c4 immediately
Queen d2 check is almost winning on the
spot let's look at it wow like rook c4
Queen c4 Queen
to take stakes g3 King pops and then
almost almost a mate doesn't quite not
quite right we'll see what he co he's
gone for it yep he's all in on the
exchange sack and what's the bishop know
there's got to be a follow-up we missed
there okay so now King F one's gonna
okay Queenie six is coming which is the
trick hey Carlos got his eye on the e6
so we're at Bishop III here
I guess use of Queen e2 it was Queen e6
as well it's gonna be a draw right I was
thinking but I can play four more too
cuz thing is to give a check on c1 the
Kings runs the g2 safely mm-hmm and
there's actually some funny variations
there's a Queenie - yeah I'd see my
check nice play by a car there actually
but check this out Queen c1 check okay
King G to h3 check okay see now if ruck
takes its mate
oh my but you know Kings - he's just
fine I'm just sitting pretty over here
yep I'm sure he karo is already
calculated lines like this that's
actually that's actually super
irritating if you're dobro you felt like
intuitively this was an exchange sac
that was gonna maybe start the match off
in a way that people didn't think but a
car Nakamura goes to convey matumbo and
shakes his finger and Wow
just like that defends and gets his
first victory and he was in the chat to
saying or is it just gg is it just GG oh
is it an attack or GG yo is this gonna
be a blowout does dobro have a chance
well that's gonna lead us to our daily
question for the first time in the day
obviously many people know that hit kora
Nakamura is as good at this thing called
blitzen bullet chess and we have a
question is who's gonna have the best
chance as an underdog now I think
there's a pretty obvious choice in the
selection for those of you looking to
vote directly via the chest comm
official channel on Twitter we have a
poll you can let us know here in twitch
chat I don't know if we have the twitch
extension vote working but at some point
maybe today we will you can use the
hashtag speed chess and give us your
reasoning but given that ali reza
firoozeh is in the chat and obviously he
is the underdog against Levon Aronian by
seeding I think a lot of people look at
all the reza as the guy that will that
will upset seating in the bracket but
but who knows right give us your vote
let us know if you think Dobrev has a
chance and get involved on Twitter and
we appreciate your social media
interaction apparently yeah
for sure and it's very interesting
question because you might want to go
with an underdog who you might think to
pull off the upset yep but I don't think
Dobrev is the answer to that question
maybe not right you know I'll give my
thoughts on Olli Reza firoozeh versus
Levon Aronian which of course is coming
up this week I believe they're actually
up yeah they're the they're the first
match on Thursday I think that's gonna
be that's gonna be tough right obviously
I was the mass mite that was the huge
minority when I picked away ye to beat
only Reza firoozeh most people laughed
at me but I do feel that the stronger
players in a long match at this point on
the Reza is about to break into that I
would say elite chess group but he's not
quite in that top 15 in the world right
and you look at those guys and I think
the Purusha is the underdog for a reason
so I have LaVon in that match and maybe
I'm given all the rest of a bit of
motivation here yeah he's hanging out in
the church hanging out right but okay
like obviously we know that all the rest
bullet performances in the world along
with guys like a car Nakamura so that's
gonna be an interesting one I'm very
excited for that match yeah that match
will be very interesting as well as the
second half of a doubleheader where you
have Artemia playing against Sasha Gray
shook and that's another one where
complete toss-up in my eyes and they
know that's the cop-out answer saying
it's a toss-up but both those players
are super strong we know from past years
how seriously rook takes these right
he's really prepared he's fighting to
the bitter end and he was the first
victim of young Christophe Duda right
the legend of Duda the legend of Duda
was being real by beating rook yeah and
an epic comeback yeah and then it only
got further this year when he made this
huge comeback for those who didn't if
you somehow mission these Gary versus
young Christopher Duda that's it that's
the word you don't want demand worth
watching back up and check it out either
here on Twitter or on our YouTube
channel because that was a for the first
ever real for game comeback we've had in
the main SEC yeah because we've had I
get I say real because MDL was just down
four games against wayy but it just
never felt like he wasn't the heavy
favorite that one was one that seemed
like it was Gary's match to win and
young christophe Duda came all the way
back the comeback kid
wow look at this Bishop a3 yes hitting a
knight oh and the Queen on c2 is under
attack but there are many pieces hanging
in this variation yeah this is what
happens in lines like this we get
chopped
chop-chop-chop maybe even chopped but
then chop and juice on it
rook on b1 hangs in the end wait I'm
sorry their work goes to b1 exactly but
then there's Bishop e6 there's no g5 and
this is a world of nuttiness I mean too
much calculate some calculation here hey
Carl's like why are you making me work
right now
oops why are you flipping the board an
don't flip the board an that was my
nickname in high school yeah you did so
many queer I had a lot of nicknames in
high school it was weird we I don't know
where that nickname came from I don't
flip the board Dan it was a long night I
don't know where you're going with this
i'ma let you keep going here keep
digging that hole buddy speaking of
digging holes thanks to everybody that's
here in chat I'm gonna dive in and
acknowledge all the chatters for the
first time today we know that's a
dangerous thing to do sometimes but our
boy daryl morey just showed up we love
him rockin and rollin on twitter
thanks for being here Daryl those who
don't know grand Grand Master of the
Houston Rockets yeah he's a GM yep
shout to the chest TV chatters we got
national master Joseph trulson Diamond
member span and three four crazy coffee
man thanks for the thanks for the
moderation today over there appreciate
everybody that's here and 3,500 of you
don't go anywhere
we got a full day of chess ahead and
it's really not every day okay finally
the move the Queen moved off from the
sea to square but yeah for so many
movies the Queen's just under attack and
finally it runs away but this situation
the bishop on a three then item before
just feels very well placed and you
can't dislodge it with the pollen a five
there and now with Knight to b5 you to
watch out for it c7 squared the d6
square so there are some elements I
certainly like for Vlad in this position
but are you going with legislate cannot
have to debate Dobrev is it dobro
vertebra I asked them Nicolas Nicolas
Nicolas Nicolas Nicolas Nicolas Nicolas
okay all right all right we've got rook
da
now the Knights gonna come in before c4
right take your take your pick
c4 love it my favorite too and he's
giving us at least a five is on
so he's giving up the a for pawn but
there might be some issues on the B 4
square that he can go after but the
bishop can always swing back to f8 so
here night on I see father's Bishop
takes b4 always hanging pieces right so
95 Bishop takes b4 8 takes before Queen
before just this looks probably should
be level in opposite color bishops
position in fact here car oh and she had
saying free pawn but maybe he decides
he's ok with giving it back as he likes
his new position for his night and that
pawn on e4 blocking the bishop on g2
right oh look at that
whoa dobro of going full miscalculation
by a carro mode that's that's a lot it's
a mouthful but that's cuz it doesn't
happen that often
it really doesn't Hikari he definitely
overlooked that big c4 is possibility
because they're two pieces protecting it
right and the bishop was the only piece
attacking it but the knight was pinned
that's a queen e7 here is one move that
I would certainly consider pinning the
bishop on e7 attacking the rook on d8
and eed overall he's putting up a good
fight here yeah yes I mean I'm looking
at the position it's still kind of
dangerous right because you got to look
out for the Brooke infiltrating to the
second rank f2 is a weak spot right so
now Queen c7 is kind of calling the
bluff on rook D - what's the follow-up
you could hear the hesitation of my
voice is that something with rook a 1
taking a vanish the fact that the bishop
is pinned maybe and then they're under
stakes F - it's gonna be nutty right cuz
something like this happens everyone to
show Roberts lined up rook takes F - the
point is King takes balls in - Bishop
takes g3 with check and there goes the
lady but you have your rookie I can
already hear 184 he goes for it but does
he miss this idea - huh go Queen d hxi
in term is aright so Brooke takes F -
you get the Queen out of the way and
then gobble up yourself a rook like
you're working one move actually it was
very interesting because the problem was
there were some checkmating ideas that
black-headed
yeah keep an eye on yep so first except
who was not possible so I'd like your
move okay one more yeah he could have
done this everyone again the point is
the bishop was pinned for a moment and
if you take here the idea was rook a a
check and some sort of Queen of fate you
know the king could go here in the rain
oh yeah so maybe that would have been
nutty yeah okay well 94 rook t3 hey Carl
keeping the pressure but for the first
time I believe down on the clock I don't
think it was ever done on the clock in
Game one so if you're just joining us
thank you for being here this is the
2019 speech has championship
there could be get the biggest event in
online chess eSports if that's a thing
but well b5 is played guarding a8 that's
a nice move by Hikaru sneaky defense and
he's opening up tactics with rook takes
III at some moment oh my gosh this is
gonna be one of those hey karo time
scrambles heard around the world here so
this is this about he gets super
dangerous yeah Queen ehx of King G some
9686 in there okay seven videos this now
you see but then he's no king f6 96 he
gets the King out what is happening here
and there's Queen h8 check stuff that
King might just keep running that it
might go full force Gump
I'm I'm nothing saying I'm speechless
right yeah 96 king of fate what white
wants everyone is obviously to get this
rook involved with a Tempe right then
the mating that is on whether it comes
to the seventh rank or the six ring so
the car was gonna play king f6 now the
question is can you give a check and
then play the rook to the sixth rank
with check right and this is so Queen da
check males
pull up the analysis right so Queen
recheck okay King take c6
yep rook a six check he a five where's
your next check I don't know I was
hoping you had something for me Queen d7
and then King g5 and then reach for and
you get to h5 run forest run he's going
for it this is gonna be the second
attack that dobro goes all-in on and
comes up a little short
I mean his shoulder that was awesome
wow that was awesome okay I gotta bring
back the analysis where to see the
ending because neither one of us and I
saw it coming and then it happened right
before our very eyes Dobrev
says this will not be a shutout nor an
adoption I'm gonna make a call right now
the Technos best chance to get an
adoption started here I don't know that
it's gonna happen and Wow
look at this final combination we were
anticipating Queen d7 as you saw an H
for silly Dan mating adapt mating
attacks are for kids or Russians in this
case because Dobrev knows had to do it
better than me
rook f6 the point is if takes Queen
takes the king was trapped so obviously
it was just over if there's not a mate
and obviously if the king had moved to
g5 something like rook f5 is the kind of
double checks you you ride home to mom
and dad about because that would that's
a mate wow that wasn't that was nasty
nasty good good stuff there by dobro van
keeps all of us entertained obviously we
know he can are Nakamura the heavy
favorite for a reason but Dobrev is uh
he's bringing it today if you're just
joining us the first game that did not
go big Vlad's way was also an attack it
was one that he brought the pressure and
Robert I've been highlighting for dobro
to have a chance today it's gonna have
to be an aggressive tempo that he sets
right he's got to try to hope and cross
his fingers do I catch a car Nakamura on
a bad form day because I know he's he's
better than me and in all these time
controls so um speaking of we got all
the time patrols we got all the events
going on let's remind everybody of the
events that they can follow twitch.tv
slash chess for chest comm TV you can
see the full calendar obviously the
speeches championship Robert running
along but you and I the reason you're
sitting next to me we flew you in to
Studio C here for a reason because the
Fisher random quarterfinals for the
world Fisher random Chess Championship
is throwing down this weekend yup we got
eight great players including Hikaru
Nakamura competing in that but if you
look at that cast of characters there I
mean just super-strong world number two
Fabiano Caruana
Wesley so vidi gujrati you know early
razor Perugia who will be competing in
the sec this week against Levon Aronian
Peter Svidler
and Vladimir Federer Savin yonder
palmistry rounded out those three
Russians at the top it's amazing
honestly I'm so excited for that event
me too
we you and I have never commentated yet
on the official random no I played I
didn't come late and you did fantastic
right you had the fans on the edge of
their seat you you actually beat one of
our
players here oh no you didn't head over
I'm sorry I know I thought you were
paired with Dober in the first round no
you were paired with Petrossian
I was and and you you beat the Armenia
and then you ultimately felt a surrogate
Corey Aachen so I'm not trying to astok
it was great right you had plenty of
winning chances but while we have been
fans of what has become a three month
four month long event here on chess calm
you and I get to commentate on the
quarterfinals a lot of prize money going
up this weekend as you as we just showed
so make sure you clear your weekend
calendar and be with us to watch the
fish of random World Chess Championship
so someone in the chest TV chats or an
chefs saying who is this dobro guy plays
a lot on chess calm and qualified his
way in so no one needs to ask who the
car Nakamura is but definiteness we need
to ask whether uh whether this is gonna
be a close match a car looks like he's
about to rebound here this is gonna be
crazy game but his queen she - yes he's
nothing he's a knight takes beat over in
92 b5 because the knight on f3 is
protected yep
now the queen guards the night Cassie
between so much more more castles Queen
said yeah yeah okay
so that's a Cora's idea to take with the
night and he does this looks really bad
so my first instincts were correct that
it did look bad for Doberman then I saw
the rook
I saw the Queen coming to g2 and and
then he just played rook h3 which of
course were news the threat of the
double attack but there's some
possibilities here so if you Castle
queenside for white which seems like a
very natural with Queen c6 check King b1
that rook takes on f3 and now I have
three minor pieces you're getting some
material right who knows yeah that's
that's the kind of messy game you need
is black from the starting point but
that's why Brooks seemed one so the
castling there's no checks I won't see
file for black the bishops a ninety
seven will be protected now when I give
you that check and your Bishop is
nowhere to go because if you go Bishop
to b7 well then I can throw in a check
and then win your Bishop on b7 anyway so
Knight b6 played nice move
you know guards the bishop can also leap
forward into c4 where and with the rook
on h3 there's another threat which is
also Queenie for in some positions right
right no you're not winning the material
of Queenie for happens the King can't go
to f2 but there's you know there's some
some things to figure out here and I'd
be
six cards the bishop and also opens up
the idea that the bishop might find the
G Foursquare yeah that would be very
annoying that Bishop blends and Jeb
especially because you went rook c1 your
king is committed to the center right
and so Bishop g4 it just not only hating
the knight but through the night towards
some of these central squares where
checkmate ideas can pop up take our
leaning in there for the first time he
doesn't leave dazed he does not look
pleased I saw that face he kind of yeah
yeah not his not his super happy face
but he's gonna calculate right trying to
focus on on how to deal with the threats
the natural ones we've been highlighting
Bishop to g4 Queen de for as you said
the king is committed now in the center
he goes what she won but there's there's
obvious things to calculate here rook
takes f3 probably fine for white but
after takes rook takes b6 this is the
key we're moving they're not only
tonight but also the defender of the
bishop on c8 so that's a very nice idea
and you always think about that when
pieces are hanging right yeah I know
that the rook on g6 is under attack so
you take on b3 and then right like it's
it's a desperado right now this guy's
hanging so I go here and this guy is
still hanging but white gets the last
laugh with the final desperado so those
those are those are how blunders are
made not to be confused with how babies
are made as you know whoa King f2 look
at this now rook takes f35 Bishop h4 is
about anything and then f3 is falling
weight is so this actually looks really
deep whoa so rook takes f3 I'm very
confused so this isn't this like
directly problematic rook takes f3 Queen
takes Bishop h4 check King f1 only move
right because anywhere else you move I
can take on f3 with check the king of
want and then there's got to be
something here well you can even just
take and go for the three pieces for the
rooks which is super unclear Wow
I mean this position with with the past
F pawn the rook is hanging immediately
this is not this is not gonna be simple
at all yeah and you actually even Wow
yeah that is very unclear here so it's
it's messy but maybe there's something
more if you start with Bishop each so
much more right away I mean Vlad is
thinking he goes for this line I think
we're gonna settle on the three pieces
for the rook not that it's necessarily
settling but yeah we're
maybe night 6500 yeah because there's no
main frets here comes the night I'm a
three where's your rook going from G
mate over to a6 is the only saves you
only the only hope is that you run and
that somehow blacks F pawn doesn't meet
you right okay here comes Knight III the
bishop is gonna move and then here comes
Freddie
so Bishop wherever chief can't figure it
out like Bishop g4 to hit the rook on C
you can't gain a temple there but and
here comes the F pawn classic I think we
just got a huge raid from the chest bras
I think I didn't see the alert on screen
but suddenly a bunch of people that have
been falling coverage of the World Cup
those guys have been doing an amazing
job if you haven't been with them for
the last month and you're missing out
but thank you for the raid guys
thank you for the amazing coverage with
Yasser himself and look at this - drop
it just Hikaru got out you know he
bailed him out here very nice defense
actually because we were about to get
some Freddie
maybe a little mercury for the White
King to have two there so hey Carlo
swindles his way out saves a draw which
is not something we plan to say a lot
today
yeah but a call right now kind of on the
defensive you got to give it to Vlad
right he's brought the aggressive chess
every single game has been an attacking
affair with the Russian bringing
pressure so if you're if you're just
tuning in and wondering what kind of
match we're gonna see don't go anywhere
and gotta go ahead sorry we were talking
about something similar yesterday like
what kind of opponent you might want to
face and Dobrev is one where he's just
not afraid of anybody
he knows he's objective about he knows
that he is the worst player between the
two of them guys without hate jokes
about it in the interview we gave them
it's by what music he'd be listened to
and I forget which songs he said but
specifically he was woe talking about
thank you they're there you know for the
subs we appreciate it man thanks for the
love talking about whatever music is
about getting killed right so Dobrev
knows that he's the underdog in in
today's match but my point was going to
be that while he knows he's the underdog
he's not afraid right that's an
important thing to note and so that's
why he's able to score these points
we've seen other players challenge
Hikaru and just get absolutely
demolished very well side to fair so I
think that Dobrev is ready for this and
he's making the most of his
opportunities that's right well right
now Hikaru
sending a message about just how fast he
is we see the more time than he started
with write something we'll say a lot to
up a pond and way up on the clock so he
car was like alright I'm sitting up now
I hear you I'm chatting to him I'm
bringing he's chatting he's just down a
pond for nothing
down upon for nothing and hey Carl
letting the world know that that's his
evaluation so shout out to those playing
guests to move on chefs calm we have
feed him master birudo fan I don't know
if you misspelled and was meant to say
burrito fan either way I do like
burritos
birudo fan also good stuff so those of
you hanging out on chest comm as well we
see you in the chesty Beach a shout-out
to Steffi 94 who just showed up and okay
well hey Caro is transitioning himself
and upon a bang game but it's not the it
this isn't a position where the extra
pawn is that much to write home about
obviously a Caro said that in the chat
but the truth is white does have the
bishop hair and it you know it's a
double deaf pawn it controls some
squares and if you can get your knight
to have a different duty than guarding
the d6 pawn like Bishop e5 then hakarl
can eventually maneuver this Knight into
something useful that might help the two
pawns but you know this isn't like the
this isn't the happiest sexual pawn
you've ever had I don't know I think
it's closer to a draw than it would be
winning for black and so as an extra
pawn in dealing with two minor pieces
and what black would love to do is swap
off those dark square Bishop sand that's
what high cards tried to do because as
soon as you trade the dark square Bishop
s' that Knight will dominate the light
square bishop by hopping around to all
the dark squares ya know and I'll show
that here take stakes with the d6 we're
coming Knights not only are the best
blockading pieces in many ways they kind
of thrive in these situations directly
behind pawn so this is that's what a
Cara wanted Dobrev said no he's not
gonna be such a nice guy here and thing
is look at the extra pawn it is a
doubled F pawn so how you gonna create a
passed pawn went that's the problem
double ponds right they just can't push
forward an endgame to create a passive
on the knight on b7 what's that doing
and you if but white can never trade off
the bishop the darker bishop for the
night we're gonna opposite colored
bishop endgame with like what a carro
does here he's gonna try to come to be
for one of the one of the long ideas
that he has to try to wiggle a win as to
some point play a four right to make a
sack of the a pawn too
three DEA v square where that night
might have my target things like C for
coming to be three obvious risks of
playing a four you're giving your
opponent a past a pawn but this idea I
think Hikaru is very good as we know in
these time controls of creating future
time scramble tricks yeah right it what
you've got is a situation where you know
eventually the clock will will Wendell
Wendell
it'll middle the window but you can also
Windell yeah that you're a great
Whistler I don't know what just happened
here but when the clock windle's down
hey Carl wants as many opportunities to
poke and prod and create swindles where
where he can catch his opponent off
guard so I like the flexibility a cargo
crates they're talking bullets and
bullet strategy and here comes the king
of the Queen side because like you said
for after pawn to a4 the night might
want to go to a5 the King might also
want to go to a five fray so I can go
King c7 king b6 eventually pushed upon
day for King if I may even King to b4
yeah and that's gonna be a big problem
for what yeah and we see Dobrev trying
to create enough counter play to prevent
that making Jesus looks weak makes g4g
for right now yeah wonder why he didn't
I was highlighting it he went the other
way um okay
f4 played and now now my car was putting
the kibosh on g4 I like that in and here
here we go back to your plan sac the a
pawn use the infiltration path for the
King and I think I don't know this just
it smells like a game that her car was
gonna find a way to win he was the
objective evaluation all the resolution
that she had earlier said boring I think
he was talking about the game and not my
jokes
yeah I've assumed an assumption both the
same time so multitasker I mean look at
the bishop on c1 right yeah that Bishop
is just stuck there can't do anything
the bishop wants III is quite good night
energy for went from b7 all the way to
g4 and is much improved piece that's
sure I like that let me let me get a
little highlight in there that's a path
right that is a journey worthy of Frodo
right there the night finds itself on g4
and whiteheads why does nothing to do
but just sit tight here
does that make me Sam wise yeah you or
you can you can be my Samwise to my
Frodo anytime
alright Elijah whatever Rudy I remember
real Greco you never should have showed
up if you really wanted to
work today man you shouldn't have showed
up and tuned into this because we've got
nearly 8,000 people that let's see where
the party's at
all right well yep oh you just hang
chiii thank you free but you look at
them you just like it I don't like you
know sometimes when you make a bad move
and you just look if anybody's why yeah
you remember there's thousands of people
watching online yep because in a
tournament you make the movie like oh
yeah everyone doesn't see it and now
you're just like literally the whole
world yeah now it's just over it's over
you can be our Smeagol Darrell if you if
if the three of us were on a journey to
Mordor daryl morey would be our our
Smeagol for the irony of it is the
tallest of us yeah so we'd make him the
shortest you know the shortest little
former former Hobbit all right well the
question is is there any drawing chances
left after hanging a g3 pawn in a way
that was just an obvious blunder hey
Karl working his way back 96 you're
gonna come back and watch for this a4
idea we highlighted earlier and again
even though it hasn't been on the board
the fact that hick are created that
difference in the structure and opened
that idea created those problems for
Dobrev dissolve and ultimately you know
you can't you can't just say Hikaru only
won cuz of the blunder of the cheap pawn
right that that's one of the things you
do as a strong player is create
opportunities for your opponent to go
wrong so he didn't go for a four you
know which is interesting and if he's
not going for a four what other idea
does he have to win this game because
he's just sort of going around with his
knight right now and now he's sitting
and thinking but it has to be this has
to be winning for black I mean it would
be very disappointing if it wasn't after
you have two pawns here okay mr. Sun but
give it give it to Dober I mean he's
making it like it's not that easy right
where's the break and that's the problem
with the extra pawn then the karo had
earlier zitz it's a double deaf pawn so
there's not I mean again and I predicted
this before the Jeep on fell I expect a
car to win you look at the 2-minute Plus
Time advantage and the fact that black
does hold all the breakthrough cards so
eventually you can try for something but
you know if you were to if you were
describing ideal blockading setup this
would be pretty close to it right yeah I
mean the bishop on d2 obviously
slightly improved version of this but
that's why the bishops 1c3 a car put his
bishop on a 3-2 b4 to c3 to keep that
Bishop a bit more passive on c1 but as
we're highlighting g5 is one of the
ideas you want to play but the pawn to
f5 and the only way to play g5 protected
with the knight here may not protect
much as you can bleach e5 yeah sorry for
completing everything you were about to
say there okay no I'll forgive you I can
go for a sandwich after that you
mentioned a burrito before it is just
yep here we're finishing shows burritos
yep you lost your mind on the food all
right
hey Cara changing his ideas the King's
gonna come back this way which I like
this plan I think that this will get him
the balance of what he needs which is
the ability maybe oh he goes
Knight there first but how is he still
gonna get chief five I was gonna say I
think you have to bring the King in
first here he goes yeah but III because
now there's Bishop okay it's 1985 you
can play King h5 there's no Chuck on the
diagonal and the threat is Knight age 6
and g5 yep so Dobrev gonna find he's
gonna hope to move the King oh he goes
back to f3 but that doesn't stop the
plan so I thought he might go to have to
with check but at that point 94 were to
come anyway so it doesn't matter yeah
cuz now g5 is protected so that was a
really a good King journey for the night
went on some journeys the King went over
the Kings side to play g5 in it now
after the pawn push finally happened it
should be yes move victory Dobrev taking
a second to think is there any any last
offensive setup possible here that that
maybe hasn't been considered yet but I
don't think so once g5 happens
the wheels are about to come off in fact
you could even try to bring pressure
here or really eventually try to force
white to take put the knight on g4 Oh
even better
honestly now that the king guards both
pawns comfortably you can find a new
square for your knight transfer where
the knight wants to go and how it's
gonna get there so good night g4 makes
sense b1 check last night to make some
progress yeah I thought maybe at some
point that I might come back to the
Queen side whether in two before or back
with the idea of pushing a four to get
c4 but now he commits to you I don't
know that 94 was the most he backs up
into changes
I agree I think that this is the right
long-term breakthrough he's gonna bring
the night around I think to be six and
go for a four but there's also ideas of
trying to get into here but if the
bishop was to be one then what right
because that kind of one the night on h5
but you can't get there there's no legal
way to get there so doberman this is
some Russian schoolboy defense here
right this is actually has to be when a
king h4 there okay now g4 is it kind of
a threat yeah finally here's it or is it
it looks g4 can create the blockade yeah
because you can't really go g3 so easily
with Bishop t1 ideas to keep the king
away from g4 so yeah hmm a cars probably
frustrating I'm frustrated just looking
at this so I can only imagine a freshman
he's playing it well you got to give
again Vlad some credit here right
he's not gonna buckle down not gonna
bend over he's got a one-and-a-half
score right that the the matches level
right now if you're just joining us and
wondering how we got here Dubrow has
played very aggressive very enterprising
chess this has been one of the first
games where her car was better start to
finish yeah really pushing and so you
know as you take a look at the stat
sheet there we know of course he is not
in the in the realm of OTB or blitz
level really at Picaro but he's a
talented guy and he's been a grandmaster
for many years so didn't give up that
five pawn hey Carlo has managed but he's
got night h4 o came in Cikini 4e after
but he's got the same color Bishop Oh
King was you but that can't help I can't
help no okay no that wasn't good no he
he gives the grimace I think he's gonna
throw in the towel yeah there's a long
game says I'm glad no one's watching
this no that was a really long game
there if there were any chances in the
end maybe maybe going king e4 and
risking risking the Jeep on running but
I don't know I think if we back up and
look at it I don't really think he had
anything else yeah as probably this
match strategy here or no I think he was
just trying to take his time to
double-check and as the next game gets
underway will bring up the analysis
board in just before had to be right I
just mean so after night h4 can you for
the problem is that we're trading and
you wished before after jib or is it is
it fast enough
I think it
is a g4 okay otherwise what are you
doing because I'm gonna take your pawn
the only question is whether I can play
this first g4 I get bishop back here
then I ride bishop deep to sort of thing
okay let's go for this Bishop f4 okay
g3 take 65 no take c5 oh yeah okay so
what what was the I'm confused okay so
one idea is perhaps to play for g4
immediately before trading and still
Bishop f4 this would have been tricky
and again the key line everyone is that
at some point if the moves that are
obvious go straight forward
dobro vis is winning a couple pawns and
even if you have to give up the bishop
you've gathered yourself some pesky to
compensate Wow look at Diamond member
sahs K only rated in 1936 but one guess
to move with 18 out of 36 over on chess
calm there I think well we'll find a way
to bring these little mini scoreboards
into the show at some point a little
extra screen capture cuz it's getting
kind of fun to see the flags where
everyone's from playing guess the move
right here yep
yeah like international crowd
international crowd alright but let's go
back to the main game here I yeah
interesting he maybe just miscalculated
there he did he did kind of shake his
head he kind of knew that that was maybe
not his best approach but but there you
go and now dauber takes the black pieces
he has an even by material endgame yep
but what white is trying to claim is my
bishop on b2 is better than bishop on e7
and how will that happen well if you
ever take me on d4 I take with the
bishop one before you'll see that my
bishop is going to bring new life to the
position and so that's why there's this
tension is being left but they often say
if there is a tension you only capture
if it really benefits you in some
tangible way and taking on d4 certainly
does not benefit black at least in the
past few moves in any sort of meaningful
way so right now if you take on c5 black
is ready to take back but there's some
tricks here so for example let's say I
waste a move with like h6 which might
not be a waste but take on c5 Y
different
b7 that's like with the bishop
immediately right yeah that's gonna be
very even if you take with a rook right
there's there's some tricks here at the
end with Knight b7 rook up and even if
it's just a big trade the bishop will
hit on d4 in the end I don't know but
okay Brooke c2 it's more of a just
keeping keeping in mind rather than
watch out more of the threat is more
powerful than the execution for example
right right and I see a car in the chat
saying score won't be super high because
Dobrev is refusing to play quickly the
bad strategy for Dobrev I think involves
some version of trying not to lose too
badly so you know pretty good pretty
good strategy yeah you know again like
your only chance against a guy like a
car not come or in this format is to
keep it close yeah and then you know
hope that he disconnects and bullet you
look at hick arnica more as a stat sheet
he fills it up pretty nicely right yeah
he's uh as you know he's a five-time US
Champion he's the best
Blitzen bullet player online I think if
we remove increment for sure but you
know obviously when Magnus was playing
in these events there was something to
be said that they played in the finals
every time but you know hick over
Nakamura his reputation precedes himself
you know the guy's the guy's a monster
and for anybody who doesn't follow his
twitch channel if you happen to be one
of the nearly nine thousand people
tuning in go over at twitch.tv slash ian
mcaro and if any of our mods actually I
don't know Vlad's twitch username
offhand but maybe we can sear that too
would be appreciated cuz Vlad dodo Brava
also also streams yep so it is Dobrev
and f6 by Darrell keeping an eye out of
five closing down the diagonal for the
bish 1 b2 and well I mean this tension
still exists and that's one also lived
in tension with the Knights because you
ever take on b6 with this night I'll
take with my a pawn and that not only
reinforces my c5 pawn but also opens the
a file for Rick a8 to at the a to pawn
that's a backwards upon it you might
have that's some trouble Julie white
might try a four and some of these lines
right you're trying to get rid of the
weakness and maybe improve the bishop
but still this has already counter play
for black and I agree this looks this is
tension that kind of favor
black and Robert I talk about that a lot
in terms of why does attention favor one
side of the other it's because well okay
if white ever trades here this is almost
always an improvement for black as
Robert said reinforced pawns and allow
you nuke forms of counter play so this
is something white doesn't want and so
dobro is gonna kind of sit on that point
rook d7 also opens up 95 Robert but I
think he's just gonna kind of sit sit
pretty in and ask a sacar oh how he how
he intends to win this position yeah and
you know Beth well okay we went over to
c7 now he's throwing some C takes D for
ideas with a knight on C for the knight
isn't hanging but a pawn will be
probably lost the end of these
variations where black takes on d4 than
takes in c4 so that's why a Cara finally
decides to take on c5 and I guess rook
takes c5 how does he plan to meet that
so rook takes d5 looks like the the
right choice by why not there were made
bishop d4 okay that's actually been kind
of irritating right if rook just c6
though I'm still holding everything
ultimate is still pin I'll take with the
bishop on b6 I say without any sort of
confidence in the decision because
there'll be five is but you can then
move the rod ah but then b5 I'm me five
and I get my rook in and you regret you
regret life yes so Dobrev is holding the
C file hey Cara would love to simplify
the Knights and and maybe start
infiltrating on the D fall but you know
the problem in all these lines is Dobrev
is perfectly positioned to just
liquidate everything yeah
and here was we said earlier nineteen to
be six eight takes b6 and well you have
a stare down the C file and right they
file now is opens I'm gonna swing my
rook to AE point or a5 even if you're
into that yep
right eight use a problem don't wanna
swing very well Oh a car just went full
eyes to the ceiling a hakarl on Nakamura
look number thirteen there that means
he's pretty deep when acardo's eyes roll
in the back of their head for most of
you watching that's because you're about
to go to sleep or your you know your
mother-in-law just walked in and you're
like alright but for a car that means
he's about thirteen moves in there you
go you're welcome hit karo translators
fully present
III he chooses rook c7 rather than rook
c6 I don't think it makes a huge
difference because there anytime this
bishop
take everything on v6 anyway because the
brookings yeah honest like I said just a
moment ago dobro was playing very well
mm-hmm oh so b5 okay that's why I wanted
the rook on c6 I didn't want to loud
this trade but even this is totally you
know okay but you're still gonna get
rook c2 I just don't think the most
likely result is a draw yeah and I don't
know that that really changed if the
rubriz on c6 but I hear ya preventing
that could have been black chance to be
better right
in fact I thought if anyone was dinner
was going to be black but okay here
still the situation is like you go over
up e6 ago wreck a 5 it's the a5 square
the best square from my roof know what
it is doing its job right and it's not
yes it's not a passive piece a taxes
pollinate - yeah no I mean he's held on
he's only down 30 seconds on the clock
so if your dough broke that's that's
that's like being equal in the clock
against the car oh right it feels like a
moral victory right you're not getting
flagged shout-out to Steffi 9 4 thanks
for sharing the way to play guess the
move is to just follow the direct link
to chess calm and you can follow the
game there maybe maybe we can get that
link shared on Twitch - if anyone wants
to come over and play guess the move you
just got to make moves on the board and
try to play better than the chess
players that are actually doing it so
appreciate that Steffi interesting
decision by rook a7 here yeah cuz rook
b6 now you're not taking on a - hey
we're gonna get a big tray but then ya
go for this that's so I'm wondering yeah
he's just gonna be down a pawn feels
like the wrong choice and you know we
can just show her and what's gonna
happen you show it some things before so
you down a plum stand gonna be done
aplomb but he must he must have felt
like there's just a very good holding
chance given that the other structural
things in the position favor black
double deaf pawns leave white limited
counter play and strange to me because
only white obviously can be better here
for now you know winning now there's a
passage Fontana pasty pawn
yeah that was very strange and now
acardo's got his wish which is two
weaknesses right principle of two
weaknesses you know makes a Vlad a dull
boy looking at me
looking off like what did I do here like
why did I go for that I mean we're
wearing the same thing big guy I don't
know I mean you were you were holding
just fine in the brook inning play brook
a5 ya always listened to Hess you can't
spell chess without hats back up and
show everybody again what exactly
Roberts variation was and just because
it was pretty simple E and this is kind
of a common Brook ending scenario that
sometimes you can be the first to take a
poem but end up with your Brook in a bad
square as far as guarding what's
remaining so you can you got to be
careful in those situations as Robert
was saying it just didn't make a lot of
sense to lead with this rook but the
other rook on a5 to protect b5 I've been
now I'm gonna rook d4 probably just kind
of odd this was his idea that Laura was
head had him in a tough spot anyway
uh-huh okay so it may work C sevens fall
I like trucks e6 ah yeah all the way
back here Robert highlighted back here
that when you're treating Brooke c6 made
more sense in a lot of ways because it
prevented the rook ending that ensued
and and this would have been black
chance to even be better in some
situations right you have to watch out
like you can't play rook e8 right away
everyone because if you do there would
have been 95 discovered checks but ok if
black can find a way to get pressure on
the a file this is not a bad since you
know b5 anyway right yeah you're
threatening b5 to kick the knight so
okay well vlad shakes his head but as we
know it's gonna be a tough one anyway
cuz the car Nakamura does his thing does
his thing in the speeches championship
but a two-game lead for Nakamura with
about 40 minutes left here and the
five-minute portion again shout out to
all those playing guest the move over on
chess comm we see streamer Braden
Laughlin over there repping that
Canadian flag who carry fan the CEO of
our own chess kit comm playing classic
carry and doing well doing well actually
in the top five
there you go we have I love these high
positions that we have right now because
white will at some point try to go like
g4 maybe f4 star pushing some pawns on
the kingside where's black on the
queenside can do something similar at c5
b5 kind of stuff so a very adventurous
play for both sides available here the
problem playing f4 for white too soon is
that if you ever play f4 and a lot
Bishop takes c3 supposed to worry about
giving up the e4
square but for now it's let's look at so
we've done the last move for example f4
you can't take what the bishop is Chuck
yeah or you could actually even consider
it you good actually is that the bishop
pair could be that nasty right look at
them aiming at the king side but yeah
ideally you're not trying to give up
pawns but the point is that at some
moment f4 g4 kind of stuff is coming
which you might want to leave with g4 g5
just to kick the night away from f6 for
that very reason and this is this has
been the kind of chess that Vlad has
played all day that we've been happy to
see and here he's up on the clock for
one of the first times in in the in the
match Hikaru fully fully leaned in here
he knows this is a dangerous position
for black right he's also spent quite a
bit of time yeah this is you know the
way the way you have a chance right
you've got to be aggressive you got to
be willing to play theory that you might
really challenge your opponent and you
know the worst thing that ever happens
and you and I as teachers know this when
you when we have students who say well I
I lasted to move fifty or something we
hate hearing that like I don't want that
attitude right it's not about how long
you last against a strong player like
did you ever have legitimate chances and
that that happens when you go for it you
know you know don't go for g4 now if
you're worried about Bishop before but
you could even do it you got Bishop b3
you know okay he doesn't yes 53
I think naive or you can't play Bishop
b4 here like you might want to for black
because the bishop takes f6 I removed
the guard of your Bishop on e4 so Knight
e4 is probably moved to play but then
Bishop d4 for white and it's looking
good it is looking good for Vlad here in
this game yeah I like it the bishop
comes to d3 karo saying he's bored and
shot we'll see if Vlad can give him some
to think about then and and here we go
we've got the bishop pair for those of
you who don't speak chess or French for
that matter welcome but the bishop pair
provides advantages and open positions
that's common chess lingo and something
that you got to be aware of especially
cuz the bishop pair it's much harder to
keep positions closed long-term than it
is to allow them to become open so to
speak so bishop here's a big advantage
in a situation like this so yep rook e1
very nice move it prepares both efore
and gets your rook off of that diag
also you can now play your move chief or
you've been calling for if she for
happens you know I'm busted out my emote
the only one with the chief or emote
I better be yeah I was the first and
only any think somebody else has one I
just turn left
so he's so hot right now I've never been
able to turn right I'm on the anti
Zoolander like character and kyun feels
like friend we're like don't shake my
head you can't turn my head so uh I love
but I can always I love you three and
I've always been able different left
there we go with the Hansell emotes I
love Tommy that guy
the alright Bishop D for would be a
blunder here cuz rook takes d4 who
sacked the Queen and and get get jiggy
with it
yeah back rank issue in sack rank as she
was story in my life
just made those issues worse by putting
the King on a one yeah here comes chief
for now you have an anchor which is the
h6 pawn right at some point the knight
has to jump into the Foursquare right
like when is the question but it just
has to because otherwise what's blacks
plan and I think Dobermans doing a good
job of it kind of sitting on the
position for a while and be sure before
this night takes f4 I guess yeah hey
Carlos creating threats on the e-file
here and I I feel like this position
missed its opportunity to expand I mean
we've been talking about g4 and e4 for
far too long given that they're not on
the board right now before will be
played if you give it to me with tempo
right because the man d5 would've been
under attack so he creates a new threat
Bishop a4 very nice and you can't play
b3 cos I spy a little pawn so Bishop b4
here potentially just saying I love you
let me attack your queen allow me to
play b3 in the case of Bishop a4 and
yeah then maybe maybe rocket no but now
Bishop a4 maybe oh sorry I forgot you
were going to be three I moved the Queen
to a random square in my head I didn't
realize that random square guarded b3 in
a car doesn't okay so Bishop a4 of
renewed threat here what some kind of
Bishop f5
yeah but III is hanging us the annoying
thing yeah you almost just want to move
the Queen off and get get rid of this by
taking away the power of it even queen
bee one as much as I hate to say that
yeah okay like you could you could play
queen bee one Bishop a4 rook d2 and
actually in the instead of queen bee one
well if you play Bishop h7 check okay
some idea is check King h8 only move
then take on d8 okay and then play
Bishop f5 I guess you just you can even
go Queen d5 I shouldn't go efore and
make some progress somehow but right I
mean it still looks pretty if you have
action dobro played f5 and a car quickly
responds Queenie five okay he's brought
the Queen into a spot that completely
prevents the G pawn from moving that's
actually just really irritating because
white really wanted to blow things open
and let the bishops do their thing on
the open diagonals and files but that
kind of coordination is not happening
here sixty-four frequency missed it rook
takes d4 the wonder town a car lifts his
eyebrows shakes his head says I told you
yeah I told you and dobro is like I know
I don't a car was like I I warned you
about this I said don't give me the
bishop for free on d4 yeah let me
analyze and show everybody because even
though it the hikaru is facial
expression kind of said it all let me
just remind you why it's a winner of a
piece the Queen and rook together hit a
one they have x-ray vision through this
epon and so when dobro puts the bishop
on d4 he allows this tactic takes would
have been met by shake and bake and and
there you go hey Cara Nakamura gets
another victory he's back to 3200 new
3201 if you're keeping track at home
right
not even his all-time peak what is his
all-time peak at blitz something closer
to 3300 just phenomenal phenomenal I
don't know
that's nominal I can try to check we can
open up his profile here that's the
advantage of working together not just
that we can touch elbows time to time
kids you can
all time blitz 3265 ridiculous yeah I
don't think he's getting that today
that's pretty good yeah I mean you know
Hikaru I'm a little disappointed yeah
3300 would have been better but you know
we'll give it to you
they'll keep working on it okay you know
you'll keep working on it
we've got about nine thousand of you
with us still thanks for being here
whether you are tuning in on chest comm
TV or twitch.tv slash chess or one of
the many places on the web that this
show it might be embedded I don't know
thanks for being here either way hit the
follow button it's purple
it's pretty you'll get alerted the next
time we go live from twitch so there you
go oh I guess I should do that well
because I I know I know you already
follow us no I don't and we've got we've
got some tweets of course the daily
question is which underdog is most
likely to outperform their seating we
talk to you about our opinions quickly
earlier we know that Dobrev is a heavy
underdog here and he knew it
heading into it but we've got some
answers so based on these percentages
that you're seeing in the vote that's a
direct reference to the fact that if
you're on Twitter you can vote directly
so please do it give the official at
chess comm channel a follow on Twitter
as well firoozeh obviously gonna be a
favorite for sure a lot of people like
firoozeh and we know that our timmy of
is an underdog and speed chess with a
question mark it's the good point in
fact I can tell you my partner here
Robert you really like our timmy of
chances in that match I do I'm a bit
more of a Sascha a Homer yeah I just you
know I feel like Grichuk is a world
former blitz former world champion for a
reason but does that mean Sascha Bart
down there by the way I mean that is a
fro for like is he preparing to cornrow
that thing I don't know what it is I
think we call that the the mushroom top
the the helmet hair let's just say it's
hard to get a dart through that thing
protective protective gear hurt if ative
is a super super talented kid I say kid
obviously in his early 20s but he's
rising through the ranks not only in
Russia but on the the world standing so
I
he got he got an invite this year and
we're looking to see what he can do and
grow shook has been very complimentary
of him because when they played in the
World Team Championship they're like oh
with no chronic anymore who was the team
leader of Russia and he said he called
him the Chuck Norris of Russia right
shout out to all of our subscribers you
coming in all of our premium members
with you these shows are possible we
appreciate the support means the world
really it's really not it's not just
like jokes like with you is the reason
we're here so thank you for your support
and look at this after three is not a
movie not a happy move for a car oh that
D for scores calling my name
juicy right mission one g2 though I'm
scared of you right
alright but night if I was actually a
really strong move not just because of
the the polka John D for but also the
Chi three pawn here yeah and why can't
really afford to take on f4 because then
when ting with the e pawn it opens up
the bishop the G file is open for Brooke
to come to g8 it's just not nothing you
ever really wants to do is white yeah
and again they'll roll this up on time
so give it to him right yeah no it's
he's playing pretty well he's been I'm
getting outplayed in certain positions
of course as we you know we continue to
mention a car is the high rate in
stronger player but dobra Dober wasn't
putting up a very very good fight and in
this one too he seems to ooh
g4 that's a that's I feel like that's a
bit of a win for hit karo to have closed
up the potential tension because even
with h5 coming okay unless you find a
way to go to full sack town I feel like
that slows down things just enough that
my attention turns over here and wonders
what yeah he's gonna take with the a
pawn I'm already liking every end game
for wide okay d5 though very smart just
open up is upon d3 that's a clear
weakness and he's going after it right
now so 94 you know I don't want you want
to play anymore yeah I think I'd rather
put on a 5 and he played it before I
could highlight it because the point is
if you trade in the end I get d3
anything to keep the D file open it's
what black wants right you want to get
after that target and the problem is if
you put the 9d for little your Bishop on
g7 just
Oh what is it chorus II I'm I don't see
what he sees caught me off guard so I
take on d4 at the pawn let's see I don't
always Bishop before ah okay I see says
the blind and yeah that looks pretty
good then he's going oh wow I was like
you're right I mean just yeah
pretty obvious move what it's like that
pawns didn't look like it but okay even
this is still not so clear right the
dark squared Bishop is an asset for
white and it's gone if black can can
find a way to get his Bishop going
there's there's potential there right
but so he plays d3 yeah Bishop c3 or
Bishop d4 to e3 yeah I don't I mean okay
I think the exchange sac gives gives the
car the material he wants but this is
not an over over and done with game yet
Bishop c3 right now looks quite
reasonable the F for pawn is hanging in
many variations but okay so Meghan for
Queen C for Queen c2 but the fishes by
first just hangs f4 that's the problem
with the move order yeah he sits back
and again kind of like what what am I
doing here
rook d8 again he's got all his hopes on
dawn over here what's Darrell down as
Daryl Morey in the chat so we'll go with
the D pawn Daryl a lot of hopes on Daryl
reaching d1 I was hoping to be Donatello
hey you know how I love my ninja
generals I sure do
cowabunga wasn't gonna go there but you
know sometimes you have to I no choice
it's a childhood memory that we try to
keep getting you to move away from clean
up for whatever roof takes d5 ah
followed by Queen b8 inmate that's
positive rush yep puzzle rush because
Knight b3 is the movie you want to play
as a response is why he wouldn't be
shout out to JT cannon in the chest TV
chat says why does y need the attack
he's already got material I love it like
come on save some room for later Augusta
say some room for later
you don't need everything in one meal
like our oh yeah that's uh that's true I
feel that way sometimes in my position
like I'm
I already sacked a pawn like why do you
have to have the compensation because it
wasn't a sack hey that's the twist
all right well dobro still has chances
riding on Daryl here but Hikaru is gonna
take a think and kind of just out race
him here comes your you're a wizard
Harry
although yep some kind of Queen trade
might not make it so clear but I don't
see how you get the Queen III Queenie
free I can't play h6 because you trade
and then take you know it's rare enough
for you to take on yourself
oh yeah it's check actually so I can
just ignore you let's analyze it takes
h6 Bishop takes age six oh I thought I
was gonna find a way to get in here I
mean that that's kind of a move you got
to worry about right I don't disagree
right hidden everybody at once but he
puts the night on e3 in the game and
Hikaru achieves h6 nine takes it five
protects g7 that's irritating yeah that
actually I wonder if Acorah missed that
he leans in here like wait a second
that's not ideally don't forgot about
that
okay so much so that he's gonna take it
but now you're now you're really all in
that this dark square is gonna lead to
mate how sweet would it be if you don't
be so nasty now I'm crossing my fingers
so like if you go back and just as we
show that yeah fun to show 52 let's say
DT right looks good now Rupp d7 hey I
stopped you're me but Queen g7 you
didn't stop my bait pause a rush that
would have been that would have been
sweet okay don't Rove sees this at least
slows it down for the time being and
David no creatures Ovid knows I would
know what's up made the g8 squares free
oh I thought it was the same thing I
thought he actually missed it the point
everyone now is if takes check the King
has a square so oh man
you scared me though I've got to take my
bets morning oh so who's getting made it
first that's the essential question you
can't move the rook off the back rank
just yet cuz they're queens III though
and the Queen is overwhelmed Queen a1
check we nee won the king runs up Bishop
e5 King age three runs into rookie three
knows every pen d3 yeah okay so is it
just
you you can put Queenie five and try to
liquidate into a situation yeah so it
was Queen f1 so he's not gonna most
likely a peaceful more insult now
birthday stage six of Czech yell
actually push this lack should push it's
there's only chance in the match you
gotta push games like this yeah try to
bring the rook to g7 even though it mhm
yeah actually that's just gonna it's
gonna be a draw
yeah what a Bishop h4 here okay he's
gonna push h4 and try to do things with
the rook this should be five rook g3 he
has to try yeah yes to try he can only
be better yeah but that's you know a lot
of people say that as their last words
against the car have you ever watched
Eric Hanson stream I can only be better
wait a second how do I lose that yeah
shout out to Erica and the chess Fras
and their World Cup coverage by the way
if you're not tuning in go to twitch.tv
slash chess brought it's been amazing
looks like we're getting closer to a
winner with Dingley Ren right now ring
ding ding who's at my door I'm Magnus oh
it's tingling rent coming to knock on
that World Championship match door you
almost sound like Edgar Allan Poe that's
right the okay rook she's seven you're
holding b6 already you can play h4 but
then Takara will put the bishop on g4
and there is no rook g3 all the time is
now not really on Bishop f5 honestly
this is something I told you the famous
last words against a carro is only I
could be better here and then you lose
ya self all right well it's a rook h8
have King g5 okay he goes there anyway
time favoring a carro position favoring
nobody King h4 okay Bishop put the
Bishop on c5 even there's no threat of
e5 try to get your king in and play
roach e3 if you're okay try to try to
move a little faster now because you're
under ten seconds no choice for efj I've
rookie three actually okay hey car was
gonna win this game somehow yeah I don't
know how but it's just I I'm starting to
agree with you it's there's nobody's no
business winning this game well you want
time
Vlad's like lost track of that one Oh
my gosh I don't want the fans to lose
track of is the speeches championship
schedule as flat tries to gather himself
after that one let's remind everybody
that we got a busy week you and I are
gonna have a voice of soreness the voice
of soreness on October 6 you get to go
to the Isle of Man after that and but
anyway we've got a very exciting week so
if you're tuning in to the chest Channel
here for the first time make sure you
give it a follow October 2nd tomorrow
Mahmoud yar vs. Wesley so that's that's
I mean every one of these matchups is a
coin flip so Nakamura Dobrev is I guess
a good way to start not to say that this
match is over but let's be honest this
is not gonna be a coin flip right but
mom a jar of so who do you got in that
man I have no idea save it for tomorrow
I did love Wesley's comment when in the
interview yeah he's like oh well what do
you think about this matchup he's like
well what am i what do I think about how
did I get mom and Jaros my first run of
course after that we have Aronian versus
Perugia as the first match on October
3rd starts at 7:00 a.m. Pacific time I'm
gonna make sure you don't stay up too
late tuck Ian's real nice I'm ready for
the guy with glasses your bedtime is my
kids bedtime on that night and putting
you to bed ok Purusha and Aronian your
room for the guy with glasses lol I just
got that okay the next match on October
3rd is all Russian action more hair than
he can use versus someone who could use
a few back right and these two guys
these two guys are gonna give us a
thrill ride I'm sure so I'm so glad
that's our last matter because we're
gonna be exhausted yeah Grichuk is just
gonna give us a show I mean no it how
could anyone not love Sasha yeah he's
just so entertained don't love Grisha
gets a you problem for sure that is for
sure you know you say that often and
sometimes I disagree with you about
Sasha it's a hundred percent true you
don't like Sasha chris scherk that's
that's on you yeah David broke a spark
chest and she has to be chat said OPA
Rouge is playing in this r.i.p naka i
don't think so buddy I think all the
reza would disagree with you man that to
look at this Daryl trying to get a
question the day should there be a per
move shot clock and speech s I mean
asking that's a different kind of format
you just get a certain amount of time
per move like three seconds and it just
constantly runs down and runs back to
three seconds
Alex Christian she knighted him the
night it Iran I believe Grisha Cousin
Itt run hey Bevers way to do your
commentary job Robert sorry I know this
next one gets underway let's back this
thing up and see what the bleep happened
I don't know I mean I'm allowed to bleep
myself right yeah okay so very nude we
had a okay a traditional kind of qgd
bishop before nothing spectacular but
this is what you got to do you got a
play theory yeah dobro goes in for
mainline kind of tartakower stuff here
95 solid taking up space right
was it a blunder or did he get a big
attacker in so kb4 is a very nice move
putting the kibosh on anything on the C
file mm-hmm dobro vis uh and then he
gets a big Center okay this this was
just a great game for white 94 was 94
not a good move by akaru
I mean the position I mean you can play
94 of white has to part with the bishop
right but not if you can trade the night
and keep the two bishops on the board
this is this is just bad pawns okay so
what happened here just loses the a pawn
oh and the bish 1 b2 is lost
oh so this should be 2 as a butter yeah
so if he had backed up he's worse he's
just down upon here I mean Dobrev has a
great position you bring the bishop back
and Guardi for your nice e6 actually or
even nice e6 right and the a pawn is you
know how you like them apples
yep right so fantastic stuff here shout
out to our winner of guess the move
alpha winner from France who one gets
the moving that brilliant very quick big
Vlad victory but ok we're back to the
main game and those pawns on c6 and c5
don't look too happy
ok I have 6 thematic that way you can
play for a 5 but this pawn structure so
bizarre because Lily both both sides
have pawns that only a mother could love
right yeah this pawn g4 is particularly
useful to stop f5 which is what Hikaru's
going for he went stood for he's saying
you're not getting f5 not getting Bishop
d5 in I mean you're already looking at
Bishop a3 potentially here yeah other
than a 4 comes in just a movie nobody
does it the next move just because the
rooks are connected but it could have
I didn't move whatever I think so Brooke
a5 here it looks like must rise that not
eating Roque 5 there's Knight takes e5
can I get away with it come on come on
give it to Daddy go opposite colored
bishops hey you know how I feel about
Hobbs good bishops oh actually that's
bad if you okay let's look at it I think
so it takes Bishop takes beef orange
Bishop e7 or something are you gonna get
the two but that's a really nasty
outside that has anyone yeah and I know
how to use it hmm okay well anyway he's
gonna get c5 straight up so glad decides
he can't defend I feel like we're about
to get a miniature or the other way I
think a car is just gonna win this game
very quickly you think so even material
opposite colored bishops I don't know
this King can't get out of the center
but that H pawn might be useful just
start pushing that thing king of 76 made
my Kings happy in the center
not really but I'll make it sound like
it only blocks in too bad of shape here
okay okay I stand corrected
so rook b8 I don't know I that move is
particularly necessary but oh look he's
attacking bringing the King in mm-hmm
the King on f7 is that was kind of my
thought when the bishop was landed
itself on c5 that the King on f7 would
get in trouble but okay maybe I'm just I
mean why don't we bring it all the way
to d6 I'm here for it let's do it look
at this Turkey I've actually threatens
work up one right right it's a king five
rook he8 you can't take on h7 I don't
think because the Bishop g4 does the job
see anyone he doesn't go king e5 you
played rook e1 but this would have been
interesting I liked it you play like
rook f1 and then I don't know go all the
way in like all the way me it's not just
a name it's an attitude I love it I'm
here for it and now dobro is actually
expanding I mean I don't know that
Hikaru didn't miss a chance there to get
a little more aggressive we got the the
King emote being used there in chess TV
chat diamond remember my name is Andrey
nice to meet you Andrey Andrey Andrey
I'm gonna go to the school for kids who
can't read good and figure out your name
Lee do turn left so everything's correct
here so Bishop Bishop ease
he's so pressing a little bit but these
songs we're gonna hold for black I think
yeah 7 here there it is okay and there's
my h4 then kinky for you don't know fish
b6i there's some Bishop on d5 first and
then b5 you can even sack exact I was
thinking about right Bishop d5 let's
show it okay he blaze king f7 but if the
bishop had gone to d5 look for a car to
just sack and then these pawns just one
there are two of them two of them
they're very fast and very past hashtag
run time Bishop c4 coming it's a moment
seen you do that that way like he said
yeah you've got to relocate the bishop
to a diagonal where the point is runners
you could play h4 and then check the
King off ooh that's actually this is
actually getting your attending out for
a car oh he's leaning in and the reason
is the king of six guards we should be
six so king g4 would be met by this
check yep because of that Hikaru has to
run the King backward but now now the
pawns can push ya g4 looks just inviting
why not
55 also a very nice kind of patient move
improved the bishop try to play king at
five g4 let's push all of our pawns
together so here in Ricky five and he's
probably going for that sacrifice on d5
but I don't know now the pawns are so
advanced yeah now that black herbs and
is in range here so he so could even go
on g4 or was maybe was just not quite in
time because that'd be fond of run rook
e8 this is the right idea for Hikaru
bring the rook to the the back door
where you can give checks the problem is
that g8 is guarded by the bishop and
that's gonna be irritating for white at
some homes efore has to be gonna move
probably not quite yet but why done
right actually that's a great question
g4 looks pretty good do it cuz rook AJ's
met by King g5 and now I protect me you
don't have Jesus heavy a check that's
the key thing yeah this is starting to
look very troublesome
yeah a car leaning in he knows that
dobro has taken his time
g4 he finds it he goes for it wait
where's my email g4 excellent I love you
looked as if it was gonna be anywhere
besides on the internet besides on my
computer look towards me
like Robert you're here please help me
and I don't know where is it where is it
I gotta bring this over to chest calm
and yet get down and the design team to
add it no Danny we can't just add one
emo for you and yeah why not
please you know it's funny we were to
know he's listening right now what now
as they return about sacrifices for
white exchange sacrifice at some point
rook takes d6 I guess you know moment
get rid of the bishop and then yeah you
do your thing you need your king closer
like on e6 to be able to do that but
just it is an idea that is coming to my
mind yeah so gg3 first why not why not
yeah here come the pawns and I know it's
can you stop them right so rook e8 what
is doing any Heat
yeah again it lacks the most critical
square which is g8 oh okay seven here
comes Harry Age 3 h2
that's actually the threat right now on
the board and one thing I want to point
out cuz you know I always do this look
at the a4 pawn look at the a1 square
look at the color bishop aha now it's
okay Rose got to go for it now he plays
b5 all in on this idea
what's this trick he wants to dislodge
the bishop yeah rook d8 he's hoping to
push the C pawn before today but look I
think b4 takes I don't think it works
but this is like this is crazy
calculation time but again Hikaru
understands the timing of these games
and knows when he's when it's getting
squeezed and he needs to do something
right so he's gonna make a mess of this
and try to get big Vlad to lose himself
in time pressure
yeah Bishop c6 felt weird because
invited rook the melee friends Brooke f6
but the king will go to g4 so it's not
the end of the world RGV g5
you would just love to play b4 here
right I want to so just it's just a
little too slow but he's he's
calculating it unfortunately I think
he's gonna call this just but you all
said the H pawn right let's say okay b4
we got a calculate it's do it b4 okay AP
takes I was you're okay sick yeah Brooke
a6 and ruin all my plans
I know it's my thing no I ruined stuff
you're the ruiner of the big ruiner
I knew exactly where you go load the
party Dan Oh Dan who didn't let others
finish their jokes yeah that was
actually my Native American spiritually
so that was a different lifetime man no
man Dan
oh man Dan I'm all right rook f6 here
comes King g4 like you O king g5 keeping
the bishop promise stuck now h3 is a big
threat ah that's the key cuz if the
bishop moves everyone the rook falls so
okay but here we go
h3 yeah so who Queens first that's a
great question and I Carlos got the time
to calculate because c7 you can play
Bishop d7 so huh cover that so hmm with
eight minutes left very likely we will
get one more five minute affair after
this but if you're just tuning in you
came to the right place the most
exciting stream on Twitch today is right
here let's be honest okay and we've got
a full hour and a half ahead still a
Blitzen bullet what I feel like multi
you almost want to push the Jeep I was
thinking us too and you can clean but
you know but the problem is G - English
King F - oh you just come up with the
King and out H - you might take it oh
you're giving me everything cuz you get
a new lady yeah let's show the line cuz
Robert just gave us grant route 67 me oh
it's just gonna be for just yet before
he had it butts the wrong colors
queening squares the wrong color Queen
square all the King has to do is get
here and you can sack everything so
that's why I always mention waited it
out earlier I always mention about you
dirty dog we're gonna show the line
robbers talking about if G - to get a
queen with check the king of - H - you
take everything because in the end of
these lines you get a new lady and it
doesn't matter but in the game okay
the Kings just gonna run to the corner
hit karo sees it he's running he's
drawing a card knows when Bishop is in
the wrong color corner no I mean it
always is something we do we try to
obviously add educational elements where
we can not all just bad jokes falling on
deaf ears of
of Tommy Shelby but the it's it's a
super important point right because you
you noticed it very early on and it end
up being a key storyline to the game and
we'll back up quickly for those of you
who don't exactly understand what we're
talking about why this is such an easy
draw we will but we will show but hold
up King of five King G I'm trying to
think about this how oh the key is
whether you can get d6
you get seven time yeah it's a draw yeah
unless well wait but yeah how can you do
this bishop yeah yeah of you and I've
ever been so silent yeah they're the
same I was just like unser what was
happening here someone's like are they
okay
sorry you guys probably why is gonna
we're able to show you why it's a draw
right here yeah because this position
despite being up a piece and a pawn you
are unable to get the King off of the
dark squares we will show it to you on
this analysis board again you can put
your king wherever you want doesn't
matter you can have a million and a half
moves eventually you're just dealing
with a corner pawn versus a king because
to trap it in the corner is stalemate if
you make any move here if you move away
the King goes back and if you ever push
stalemate there's no way for the bishop
to force the King out of the corner and
again Robert Hess gets credit for
highlighting it as far back as even way
before this position something with the
rooks still on the board we were already
talking about definitely had to be great
winning chances there yeah I agree I
mean we're gonna focus on this next one
it's likely gonna be our last one of the
five-minute portion here but no there
were winning chances there for Vlad for
sure I think it was winning yeah yeah I
see how there is has been chatting up
there as well but I definitely whoa what
what is this King us on f8 how did that
happen
yep well if you're one of the nine
thousand people just getting here don't
go anywhere
the speech has championship they're
gonna have a very very busy week and
this match is still plenty ahead so I
hit that follow
it is the biggest event in online chess
and we're glad to have you with us we
got Mahmoud yerevan Wesley so tomorrow
Levon Aronian and Olli Reza firoozeh
artemyev versus Grisha I don't even know
what my favorite Rito is I just know I'm
gonna enjoy a burrito with my favorite
retail so we're getting burritos after
this for sure the more we talk about it
what is this position I don't know I
mean all I know is that Vlad doesn't
know either cuz he's down a minute on
the clock against the car which is
that's not the medicine that you order
like how do I beat akaru
like get down a minute on the clock said
nobody ever right so so well but but
okay he's trying to figure it out
because wait can he just trade play
Knight f3 and King is in trouble but
Knight g5 your voice gets higher you
know I've been a g5 but 96 also protects
h7 by blocking the Queen offers a queen
trade
can you play Bishop d3 though I know if
g 6f 6 falls and if F 595 just going
all-in for that pawn I mean the bishop
on d6 looks weird you have to go b6
Bishop e7 look at that move he tempts
fate does take my pawn Bobby Fischer
never gonna get that about Bishop
c4 but okay de bravas is still Dobrev
Nikolas in garage Nicola Nicola mmm
wait all right 19 BC dobro dobro okay Oh
Bishop f4 check got it
yeah you couldn't move the knight
because the bishop gets out so just to
show that real quick a ruse it's not
there be 619 be safe be sick you take b6
or f6 there's check first yeah and then
you would apiece so there's no just
discovery on the bishop there yep so
there you go
Knight c3 back just calm cool and
collected trying to play Bishop d5 and
trade bishops yeah at the right moment
okay Bishop b5 you want to get you want
to get action in here you want to get
some hitting on the d7 pawn how do you
do it play a four here okay that's a
nice move actually it says this Knights
not gonna get in
right shout-out to the the bits there we
love you thank you so much supporting
our channel means the world thanks you
for helping these events be possible
appreciate it
be 492 okay black is expanding this is
how you unwind the dysfunction feel like
we're in a Sicilian now yeah suddenly
we're in a Sicilian and ooh not the move
that we're gonna see okay but the D pawn
is still the weakest on the board and
and the 96 is looking up off side over
there 95 can be played right now I've
and things black doesn't have a clear
path forward
I definitely blacks position more than I
did earlier but I'm not seeing a knight
DD e6 check is it also possible 94 yeah
wait what's that I don't h5 which is can
we show that yeah let's do it
what was wrong no mister I said 95 we
run 96 and King e7 ah it's super
annoying sometimes you have to complete
your own variations there should be five
yeah Hikaru is unwinding you doing what
he does best
slowly wiggling his way 95 will be
annoying
coming up the FI Pont is hanging yep can
I just steal the a5 on yeah he does I
thought about c5 being a square that
forked a6 and d7 but Knight takes a five
is good enough
you said yummy yummy yummy right it
might tell me I want to go Bishop c6 but
I you know cuz I'm trying to play for
some Forks yeah I love how aggressive
you get when it's other people's pieces
always you know looking for sex on the
brain yeah this just looks good for Vlad
actually he's have a pawn hard to
imagine it not being good for him okay
two push-ups is threatening 95 rook c8
makes sense e8 defends it put the knight
back on b3 and renew the thread yeah why
not
I guess 93 I played d6 okay but you're
right then this is hold the square
can be won also just prophylaxis that
means kind of play some defensive moves
right avoid the opportunity to blunder
when you make moves like that where you
just get a king off of an open file okay
that's actually really irritating
look at that bishop on e6 suddenly like
a ninja Bishop e2 here oh oh that's a
grandmaster move
let's show why everybody you couldn't
bring the rook to f1 because that's a
problem but Bishop e2 gains a tempo on
the free bishop here before you can take
f2 and if you trade not only do I win my
piece back but if you take I win this
guy and this guy you lose a piece so
Bishop e2 is that's called
playing defense with offense right there
the definition of it and now he can
trade you could you can even actually oh
wait
look out irritating that move was by
Hikaru yeah okay just defending it I
think you can play Knight b3 I think
that's the key and then Bishop takes f2
wait Wow but okay this endgame here you
have this D pawn that we talked about
earlier a3 finally give your King some
left I think a four but okay yeah
somatic Wow the way tricky for now
Sakthi a pawn to push it the rookie for
your Knight f3 to d2 I guess okay so a
car trying to trade but this night
doesn't really want to trade if he has
to the problem is this Bishop is better
than the night in these end games where
it holds both sides of the board down
but you have the clear how are you
clearly right I mean white is the only
one with a pass or for sure Dobrev is
better
well this King thing is going King King
b3 you should have played King c4 now
white gets C well Kings he was gonna my
95 check that was the problem
ah couldn't play King c4 if you did 95
check for key mode for town OOP
Flipboard tune accidental town how many
towns are you into the water
c4 well-traveled if you are I let's see
4 was good because then he could place
c5 and he wanted to prevent Keeney for
so he's trying to get here for okay and
here comes King g4 he wanted to get King
b3 first and then c4 check right yeah
now it seems like that went to waste a
little bit yeah now he's just down at MP
kind of tempo is not coming back
G
for now like someone king of four kings
III is gonna be really annoying but this
is the example of why you avoid
positions like the bishop is better than
the knight here holding holding long
diagonals and helping apply pressure the
same time look out for g4 right at some
point black is gonna be the one pushing
here here he goes here goes the push Hey
look at the h4 look at the h1 square
oh snap dirty girl I'm just you know
that's how Dobrev draws I don't know
about that positions not looking very
fun yeah hey karo outplayed him here at
an endgame that we thought white was the
potential aggressor with the first pass
pawn that being the b-pawn but a car was
playing fantastic the bishop is is a
dominant piece yep very strong blockades
the pawn as you mentioned also limits
the White King scope from game F to G
one you know and some of these end games
where the past pawns are being pushed
mm-hmm look I'm just splitting the board
that's that's what the bishop does best
right you can't ever play oh actually
you can't play ninety three because if
you trade the b-pawn well that's
actually just I said you can ever play
93 because of the trade and actually I
think a car a bishop takes d4 check oh
let's get movin Alice's board yeah then
h3 ya know what go back okay after b6
now is king c2 basic h2o it doesn't
matter the Queen gets there but I gotta
show the idea anyway if this pawn was
already on d2 everyone Roberts idea is
you get a queen sac it with check and
then you get a queen with check and you
get back just in time that's a very very
important endgame trick to add to your
repertoire but it's one tempo short yeah
and so we have this notion wait what
where yeah it's gonna dis okay she's
gonna dissipate into a draw and car ran
away car immediately recognizes that the
time is up doesn't even take the draw
use this as extra two minutes of regular
what that is right there extending your
break that's extending your break that's
experienced in the SCC form
he's like I already know the time is up
I'm gonna let my clock run out and but
wait if he loses on time he's not gonna
lose Lindsey if you loose on time he
loses because there are pollens on the
board and right that would be the way
this thing would backfire that is
experienced by a guard using the extra
break here I'm gonna uh you know I don't
know what he's gonna do with that every
two minutes but that's two minutes that
dobro is never gonna get back yeah me
he's picking on food
oh maybe someone's at the door Boober
eats sounds good we've got ninety three
hundred people here not wanting to go
anywhere because the action is really
only just getting going I definitely
know go do it right now let's see if a
car loses on time oh is that big he just
is a hammer on him like like first of
all who cares a hammer next to their
desk
someone who smashed himself a computer
before yeah you know what I'm saying
yeah that was awesome
Wow okay well we have we have liftoff so
to speak of the speed chess championship
week has begun here with the number one
seed at car Nakamura currently taking a
three game lead over the 16 seed glad to
brav as we head into the three minute
portion don't go anywhere more speed
chess championship action when we return
[Music]
eight of the most elite chess960 players
on the planet are set to clash in the
feed a world fish a random Chess
Championship quarterfinals beginning
October 4th and ending October 6th
played exclusively on chess calm it's a
game where creativity is king and
memorization is impossible and only one
player will earn the right to call
themselves the king of Fischer random
Vladimir Pharaoh Seiya ali reza perugia
wesley so Fabiano Caruana peters fiddler
yan de pomme de yoshi bitted Gujarati
and Hikaru Nakamura these players will
take center stage as they attempt to
outwit and outclass each other in a
chess variant that many consider to be
the game in its purest form the feet a
world Fisher random Chess Championship
quarterfinals will be an event like no
other with over 350,000 dollars in
prizes up for grabs it is the biggest
prize fund for any event in online chess
history will you tune in to witness who
moves on from the quarterfinals to join
Magnus Carlsen and Oslo tune in on the
first weekend of October on chest comm
TV and twitch.tv slash chests it's the
feed a world Fisher random Chess
Championship organized by June Deus and
chess calm and as you know Robert Hess
is here alongside me brought in not only
for this busy week of the speech s
championship but as that hype video just
reminded you the fish of random World
Chess Championship Paul I'm so excited
for this weekend I'm pumped No we don't
even know what positions they're gonna
be no really we don't know right and the
the team that's working on that will
reveal it to us we're actually gonna be
doing the opening ceremony on October
2nd just real quick note that after that
match tomorrow after the match tomorrow
versus Mahmoud yerevan so we're gonna
reveal who plays who and then the
positions will not be
filled until 15 minutes before the first
game on Friday so it's just it's gonna
be so exciting an event like no other
daily question like no other is
something that we try to bring you every
show we have and today it seemed
appropriate knowing that we had a big
underdog that was gonna be throwing down
against a car Nakamura
to ask which underdog do you think has
the best chances so if it's if it's not
too late get involved on social media
let us know your opinion use the hashtag
speech yes and there you have our odds
calculations Robert as you look at it we
know his car was a heavy favorite
what odds jump out to you regarding our
question huh well I would say ding being
one in 35 because for me he's a relative
unknown online and I think that's why he
stacks up pretty consistently with
maxime beaugeois Grove right Maxime was
less favored in his opening round
matchup but as you go down you see one
in 34 for Maxime one in 35 for ding and
I just don't know I have no way of
knowing how great the one that stands
out for a lot of people's got to be
firoozeh being a 30% underdog versus
Levon Aronian yeah I mean Aronian has a
lot more experience as machen and I do
believe the Vaughn is the favorite as
the stronger player despite a lot of
people I think maybe looking at faroush
is the favorite so but I think that's
much closer to a coin flip than most
people's eyes then the stats would
suggest so anyway give us your vote
follow us on Twitter of course and and
let us know your thoughts on it so our
thoughts are that the three minute is
about to begin here any any moment the
game will get underway and we will have
liftoff into the the next fastest time
which shows 60 minutes of three-minute
blitz is about to happen if you happen
to be new to the speech chess
championship format followed by 30
minutes of bullet so you predicted
coming in Robert that if Vlad was gonna
make a move it had to be in this time
control the smarter chess prediction
backed you up and said that Dobrev has
his best chances in three minutes so
we'll see if he can get this matched a
little bit closer before bullet happens
well he definitely surprised me in the
five-minute portion because he played
very well he scored three and a half
points which is certainly more than was
expected or predicted for him and I just
think that he's showing no fear and of
course it's very clear that Hikaru
Nakamura is the strong
player but as you said many times
already that if you are going to take
out one of the top seeds even in a
single game yep you have to be willing
to venture into just mainline theory yep
but also just sure like you know I would
play this if I was playing against
someone lower than I am I need to play
the same thing play the strong objective
chess and try to outplay them from there
and look at this position with the black
pieces right yeah the bishop on g2 is
just stuck behind a wall up it's not
your favorite pawn your little Franken
Bishop there and of course White's ideas
at some point to go g5 and blast open
the king side but that does appear to be
a bit slow now I think that to his
credit car is done well to shore up the
Queen side and that's why I think that
door off let's see for a little bit too
soon yeah because it's not like door of
gain anything for it in fact
yeah no pawn is easily protected I mean
okay this bishop is still a bit of a
Franken but at least in this position
it's kind of it's serving a purpose
right it's holding things together and
Hikaru did by the way get the g5 move
you called for earlier which means the G
file is open yeah it seemed like the c4
pawn sacrifice was too soon I mean the
bishop protects both efore and c4 the
night on e7 not in a spot where can
start attacking those pawns and now if
you look at the Queen side with the
bishop on b4 in d2 situation if I take
on before I might get myself a past a
pawn real fast and he doesn't like them
apples and watch out for this to be a
story line now ephors weak if you were
if you were just comparing two pieces
you kind of like this night versus the
bishop the problem is that there's much
more than just the pieces on the board
here and Accardo has a past a pawn here
he goes this is looking tougher and
tougher yeah rook c5 Queen d7 hits the
rook on 8th and the g7 palm with
checkmate and Vlad does not look very
happy you know the way just shook us I
was like nope this isn't going my way
and I need to have for something that
you can always consider here as White's
King side is a bit open as well that h5f
for you'd love to do that and be able to
swing the Queen over somehow because the
King is open but look at it Caro I mean
he's just it's this is just abuse
Surgical he's coming forward ruthlessly
but 97 is very good move because now the
a pond and the C pond well Down Goes the
C bond
oh yeah he's losing a pond do you do you
take it on c6 and I'd say 95 looked more
precise to me because now he for Falls
the problem is that these two ponds are
still just super strong combine it with
the back rank issues right the fact that
there's threats back here lurking
waiting watching the crazy crazy game
this could be a wild finish but I should
have smarter chefs currently leading
this game in the guest to move standings
but let's remind everybody the fact that
they can play guess the move this is
from last game the last game of the
five-minute portion we had someone
getting 16 out of 44 it's pretty good
yep right USA all the way but if you
didn't know you can just head over to
chess calm but we'll share a link with
you and chat how you can follow the
games directly and you can play guess
the move to try to be better than our
grandmasters or line up with them
however you're into it right in the
thing you and I both love I guess the
movie that it's educational not only to
see if they do something different than
you but even if you're falling with an
engine it doesn't help you win guess the
move cuz these guys don't always play
the engine moves right just you're
trying to win guess the move and be at
the top of the leaderboard you want to
use your brain yeah absolutely and I
mean look at this position right now
four pawns four white three four black a
seven yeah that hurts oh the pieces
falling why he put the King on h6 which
I didn't think was yeah correct the
element but okay he still has an outside
shot here at some counter play but with
e4 coming oke for preventive right now
because of rook g4 Chuck so watch out
for that and King f2 rook g4 is gonna be
mate if you allow that so not good not
good at all not good at all how do you
keep it going okay
dobro doesn't know how he's gonna keep
it going so he throws in the towel and
with that game one of the three minute
portion is in the books and the car
continuing his trend of doing a
different opening every single game yeah
he has and this has not been a
traditional hikaru approach to Blitzen
bullet where we talk a lot about the
fact that Hikaru loves his kind of be
three weapons ready to be free no matter
what they do geez
Bishop b2 Bishop g2 I don't know I don't
forget if it's a hippopotamus or a
hedgehog I don't really know I don't
watch enough wild kratts to understand
you know the symbiotic relationships
that happen between animals you got a
lesson in that line from my daughter she
honestly that was very instructive yeah
she knows a lot about animals from
watching the show I'm very well aware
and talk about rhinos and the birds that
eat the food of other keith rhino birds
Rhino birds
you know you should pay more attention I
got to pay more attention you know what
is going on in this game yeah I dumped a
I'm sort of pay attention a d6 we're
okay gets rid of that night no can you
just go like Queen e2 and eventually a
Bishop f4 maybe it's just smarter to
protect e5 well and then take the d4
pawn off the board yeah I like Bishop
before I like putting a rook on c1 new
$96 for four I feel like you were right
you should have played Bishop before
earlier unless he's gonna take on g6 and
then take on d4 and just play that way I
knew that a call to action of rhinos
would get midnight Rhino to show and
show himself he's he's lurking in the
chat at all times thanks for being here
midnight thank you for the love and all
right well Dobrev gets the rooks where
they want to be but you still can't ever
take d4 without ePHI falling right
that's the problem right so now so now
what yeah how is he no Queen c2 and you
just sit on the position
well it's why I like if we back up and
talk about your move order I like Bishop
f4 first because as you said the main
thing was that now on knight c6 you get
to put the bishop on g3 yeah holding e5
oh look there's some Queen c2 I think
your car mr. Brooke c7 is coming oh wow
it's a double threat rook to c7 and now
that you've got the bishop on this
diagonal hitting age 7 you might be able
to take care well also a6 is just
hanging that's a problem yeah he went a
6 to undermine the defense of the rook
and now this is any can't go rook c8
either Oh a piece sac
what and he takes with the pond that's
it gotta recognize that he blundered
there and is just trying to create the
best situation now yeah this doesn't
he's he's down a piece and and likely
going down in this game just Bishop e5
pawn a force on my dad just you know
keep your past a pawn it seems for yeah
pretty wise
Bishop b5 play a four to reinforce it a
six days if you okay if you ever push C
for D for it becomes a target again hey
Carter knows he needs to go for it
anyway you got to try to do something
fancy in a hurry yeah I almost want to
take on d4 at some point play Bishop III
and push my pawn to a7 because obviously
pushing that pawn is my main priority
and right now go Bishop seat
okay stop Bishop c4 which is my idea
nobody card was created some kind of
mess here I love that like seven people
made a clip of the hammer there's like
been seven different members who've
shared different clips that's a moment
of the match right there not too soon
too soon to be forgotten
what he should have done was had like a
separate laptop next to him it was
banged it as if he was beating up his
computer even funnier I got to say it
wasn't funny like I'm just going to tell
him how his joke could have been alright
d4 played which means c3 will follow but
then d3 falls so I think you Caro is but
Bishop b4 is coming so after Bishop a1
Bishop b4 okay
actually this is uh the car has created
an absolute mess here I have no idea now
Deborah was giving back the piece yeah
their car was like what not because not
only can he take c3 but then f2 falls in
a lot of positions I guess he's gonna
just start picking up the pawn chain
take you out
c4 take d3 and claim that's enough black
does have some back rank issues to deal
with
so Bishop takes up two right away Oh
Queen takes c4 then that would have been
pin Oh woah that was kind of weird by
hikaru so why does now up two pawns yeah
we should honestly you know he didn't do
this intentionally right he no he
recognized that it was better to just
keep the blockade of the obstacle bishop
yeah he know he's got the dark squares
he stumbled in I'm saying from Dobros
perspective he stumbled into something
where he liquidated her instead of
allowing all these pawns to stand the
board right he took three pawns for the
piece and now he's up to Pollan's right
on the Queen side there so sometimes
when you're up material often you want
to see can't always say but from the car
was perspective I mean this is the right
choice I guess to just now make dobro
beat you right because it's not that's a
clear plan to use these eight
when Black has complete control over the
dark squares right but I do think that
you know just from a principle point of
view giving back material when you're up
significant material to clarify the
situation can often benefit you yep
especially in blitz from a practical
point of view when you're already down
admitted on the clock here I mean Dobrev
would like to just play the most perfect
technique right but what matters is
winning the games getting the W there's
and if you get yourself under time
pressure that doesn't happen but Bishop
III was pretty good but then you could
take on C 2 the problem is this F 2
square needs defense like I'm into all
times so I like his decision to go rook
d2 saying I'm not gonna rush it I'm
gonna play Bishop d3 next move and
you're gonna be probably a checkmate
over there the problem is the King can
run out right queen h7 you're gonna give
this check but if you take on g7 black
takes D 3 and gets f2 oh very nice move
let's show that line real quick just to
show you that if white had taken one
more rook takes d3 would have allowed
Queen takes F to chuck yep so Dobrev had
to play Bishop to e4 first hey Karl
immediately responds with an exchange
bishop
c6 saying Queen hates money 28 and Queen
the age 56 both mate and now that rook
kind of 3 is just very nice finish there
Dobrev gets a victory in the three
middle portion let me show exactly what
was happening there because I started
mouse slipping all over the place that's
why I don't win time scrambles because
Bishop takes d5 had Carlos actually
exchange but rather than taking the rook
just Bishop to ei Bishop to c6 reading
Queen e8 yeah that's nasty
GG yo right okay well dobro gets a gets
a big victory in the three minute
portion is not over yet
don't revs quote here I will prepare
normal a normal way okay I didn't want
to keep reading that quote this is this
is what they do to me they Ron Burgundy
means they give me quotes that I
shouldn't read on error is he's known
around the world for having a lot of
children or if he knew that I'm just I'm
not getting involved
it's actually really true so I'm looking
and I'm looking there's double e ponds
which wowzers
good thing for black because your pawn
on e5 takes drill the d4 square so maybe
Bishop c5 Bishop d4 ideas it's a moment
upon East six is your Knights never
getting to d5 yeah it's a smarter josie1
they guessed the move last round good
stuff over Tayyab nine nine who's
regularly a troller in twitch chat but
actually a diamond member over on chess
calm and and a pretty strong player
almost 2500 actually so he got second
place smarter chest took you down though
smarter chess sometimes proving that
that's a smarter yeah
and alright and I came to d4 after all
there's no 92 check and or or shakes his
head like Oh didn't see that one coming
cuz out Queen d7 my rook c7 that's gonna
hurt and yeah don't bro this like this
is a rebound game for Hikaru those are
the most dangerous kind yeah I don't
know what's to do here is looks like
it's more thee does he worthy of thrown
in the towel on this one currently
despite being down three games now back
to four Dobrev is actually at his
highest status tickle chances to win the
match at 7% which is saying something
given that he came in at 95% favor for a
card on Chamorro yep so and I see ya who
said this wasn't a close match
I see our meanie goes in there Hikaru
will win twenty and a half seven and a
half that's a what are you smarter chest
sound like that's interesting that's a
that's a shout-out to our chalk manager
of the Armenia Eagles of the pro chest
league for those of you wondering what
that is check it out protest League calm
but you know that's that's pretty close
so our talk saying 20 and a half to
seven and a half the smarter chess
prediction was 21 and a half to seven
and a half so and smart racing job
security threat buyer yeah you better
watch yourself smarter chess all right
well we've got a traditional Queens
gambit declined here to watch and the
knight on e4 trying to help establish
potential in the Kings side but this is
this is a position where white usually
is just a little better the fee and
cutout setup makes it very difficult for
black
get it attack and right as I say that
night takes up to is played
yikes cuz King F to Queen III King
effectively shook the sack out of myself
like I wasn't on camera but I was like
there'll be no king size oh look at that
the point is the bishop look at this
everybody if you take the point is
Queenie free and then Bishop a6 check
that's full board awareness Holmes -
pretty big check there oh my god hey
Cara right as I said that the fee
account structure normally pretty solid
thanks Dan right right Brooke it was so
it I'm gonna show it on the analogy why
do you resign actually well rook d1
allowed this sack if he didn't do it
what I was saying is true but in the
rook d1 okay Knight takes f2 was hurling
965 guarding e3 with the Queen I mean
it's not messing as it takes you just
take I'm not saying it's great situation
actually Knight f6 comes you've Knight
g4 94 threads you know its clothing
black is doing well because black is on
on the 95 I mean it's definitely in a
reasonable position right let's put it
that way I wonder if he either just
missed Knight takes d5 or if it was out
of emotional frustration that he just
threw in the towel I mean he goes goes
Dobrev is also going towards my
prediction yeah that was a rough one
there and Wow
but that's the thing is right when you
blunder you have to just like really
just try to say okay I made a mistake I
didn't see it coming
but let me look at the position and be
objective about he wasn't he just threw
in the towel and yeah that's if you gave
him that in a classical time patrol he'd
miss it and then he'd say okay Knight 65
I'm saying no but that's a that's a good
point because it's one of the things
that's difficult about the format right
so many games back to back to back you
don't always have your emotional wits
like you do and over the board classical
to gather yourself but the best players
do I mean Hikaru talked about that when
when talking about Lee Reza you know
joining this format now saying that you
know one of the big test is how do you
deal when tilt happens right when you
lose several in a row what's the
emotional situation right yep and you
know the experience that these guys have
and knowing that they can't beat
themselves if they want to stay in the
matches
in addition to being good at chess like
a car was really good at chess it's one
of the things he does really well in
this format right if he loses a couple
games in a row he keeps his wits about
him and I mean it cars you a really
smart thing especially for blitz to
bishops a lot of open space Queen takes
e4 isn't Bishop f3 so I'm gonna win it
b7 pawn after the a6 pawns it's not a
free pawn and those are the bishops need
is open space open diagonals so I think
this kind of setup for a car is perfect
although it's like this make very good
move yeah it's very very saying I'm
gonna keep the structure as is so that
this bishop is not your favorite piece
and the bishop on e7 might quickly turn
into a much better complete Bishop c5
watch out for h4 right there's some
weird ideas here where if Y can take
here and follow it with E 5 that could
be a real problem
yep so Dobrev has to be careful about
bishop takes up 4 because of that he
gets the Queen off of the staring
contest with the bishop King f1 so as g3
at some moment is gonna threatened to
trap this night but tonight he's trying
to run via h3 back to g5 yep so huh I
mean I just can't move the car was gonna
try to Jamie Foxx that idea of trapping
the knight slow Jamz
he's gonna bring the Bishop to g4 to
guard h3 and then try to renew this idea
I like it actually I like it a lot this
move also prepares h4 exactly because h4
it takes away the g5 so let's just show
it right if okay if if you had done
something else and h4 comes with tempo
then g3 followed by King g2 traps the
night because g5 discarded so Jabra
voluntarily retreats so that he can
maybe have a move here to think about
how he's gonna deal with h4
unfortunately he's not sure how to deal
with it anyway she's six maybe g3 still
coming ooh
what what what oh man takes Queen d7 you
just won a pawn even a car was like what
why not at least put the Queen on e7 to
hit age 53 so he's trying to escape it
but I can play e5 now that's the thing
that all
so yes that looks pretty promising I
think that Hikaru is picking flavors and
which flavor because look at that
accurate calculation he picked my
favorite Baskin Robbins flavor which is
everyone always says butter pecan is the
trapped Knight of the ice cream world
that was brilliant a queen of one the
Knight does get out here so you
challenged me and I did my best you know
we've got a lot of people playing guess
the move now I love it and I love that
we have a live leaderboard it updates as
it's going so I get to see people who's
winning and yes going on expertise
forties currently in first place with 8
of 18 wouldn't even use your name like
that how could you not be the expertise
that gives smarter chess another run for
his money they're coming for his Jo B
today yeah everybody you look at that
okay that's a good move now if a Caro
trades we got a problem with the bishops
on the third rank yep that's actually
how do you deal with this move Knight
before if Brooke c2 is and I was
thinking you could almost play Brooke d2
but okay puts the bishop they're
allowing rooked to d2
sorry Brooke c2 okay so he's just saying
that he does have a pawn but the knight
does come to d4 but Bishop c4 mm-hmm
gypsy for working in wait a second
anyway ii 94 okay
Bishop to d3 what's going to say was
there some like Knight f3 rookie to
ideas but now they owe some sort of
mating idea well look at he akaru super
smart give up a pawn and keep the two
passers that matter here comes six yeah
again
Roberts idea here was that if white
doesn't go for this and maybe tries to
just keep it simple then things like
this come into play and there may be
like mating nuts over here on the king
but if ro aware of that doesn't allow it
instead simplifies with a couple of
passers nasty d7 check unstoppable yep
d7 followed by baby girl Elizabeth on e8
and Dobrev is uh
yeah okay alright Bishop a6 digo
bloomenfeld yes I love it if everything
is when a car plays openings that I play
that he regularly ridicules me for and
says like you know every opening you
play is bad Danny you know one of the
many one of the nicest things the car
has ever said to me actually your
openings are yeah when a car plays the
openings that I play makes me so happy
but what if he is just Pappas if he gets
destroyed he'll be reminded why I play
bad openings not him so so how does
white continue here because you know if
I 2 moves at once I've been nice for the
f5
I try to this is this is why you don't
play the booth oh this was so bad for
black this is so bad
Oh a car ooh oh I've never go full dan
buddy he had to take what the f Ponte
six I think we should show that yeah
let's back it up and show it if you if
you take so what's about to happen now
it's horrible for a car if you take with
the D pawn queen a4 check picks up the
night yep right instead hey Carter takes
with the F foam but we have a different
type of fork a6 and the g6 square and as
we get back to the real game don't probe
us on the attack and this is this is not
a good position for black well black is
up on so that's the good news the bad
news is there's they're a bunch of weak
squares at the g6 square the bishop on
g7 isn't doing too much but in 94 that
looks good move hit c5 so a queen c6
here queen c6 the thing is night each
for some magic yeah maybe not h4 they
just takes it cuz if you take look see
why I'm seeing when it's one of that's
why a car was shaking his head yeah if
you had taken on c5 then rook to see one
would just pick back the piece hikaru
didn't do that and there you go yeah now
just
kink is open you're not even up a pawn
anymore you're trying to pawn the attack
is on Knight h4 comes in to whatever
flavor square you're into and Heights
I don't think Yankton because this is a
game that Hikaru plays to remind himself
to stay fresh right yes
so how about 96 king of 794 something
like that like I just want to get he's
playing just smart h4 I think okay h3
also keeps an eye on g2 so that Queen g6
doesn't do anything I mean there's 993
at night D 7 no free pawn free pawn I
guess right it also opens up the H file
so you can put the knight back on at 5
and and hit h8 indeed I really want to
discover it's after 9:00 look at this
rook C 3 over 2 G 3 getting rid of one
of the defenders there yep looks quite
wise rook g3 played Bishop f8 guards e7
so there will be no Forks mm-hmm
but now you could even play Brooke okay
I was gonna say bring the other rook and
just renewed this writer of rook g6 and
rook g3 so he does it um
now the other rook can get involved yeah
that's a mating attack but I mean heck
or honestly is fighting really well here
yeah it seemed like it was gonna just be
game over now Knight d3 probably to e5
pawn yep and a fee for there's also
night at four oh yeah okay Queen g4 I
think makes sense because it you even
just threaten Queen takes g5 just to be
simple and get the pieces off the board
Queen h5 Queen h4 even as possible which
is funny as a queen travel Queen g4
Queen h4 he does it this make sense
you're threatening age 4 also
threatening to take g5 ooh free poop oh
it's a back rake
you can't take you 6 did you see go to
his face oh my god his face is like Oh
No
okay so let's see hope Queen ticket a
car oh there's like what is going on
here you just lost a piece Oh
gosh oh it's so upsetting
Dobrev is like okay ladies a million
palm where's that hammer yeah okay he's
he still should win this game yeah but
it no not I mean just absolutely nuts
they're at the point
okay well keep the light position let's
just show everybody what the tactic was
the whole point was that hey Carlo plays
96 and Dobrev already thinking the game
is almost over oh he just blundered the
e-pawn right he should have played h4
and free just back rank but it Dober
uptakes here thinking he's winning a
queen or more and 97 exposes the back
rank Dobrev would have lost on the spot
so Hikaru is back I mean I'm not
necessarily a driver's seat but this
position is just Hikaru was silly table
of tricks are for Hikaru that was
ridiculous
but he's also up like knee collection
you gosh Nicola English if he's up for
pawns for that Bishop just push them all
yeah push him baby
okay well now f4 is falling so that's a
problem yeah at five I guess you can try
might as well little tickle yeah that's
a good 94 but the good news for with the
King exactly he's just or always just
winning yeah we agree was like oops
yeah it just blundered that he was like
he forgot that Knight takes B three
removed the attacker yeah now he's
getting his King in unnecessary rook c6
is almost made but the King goes to e7
that Kings is running yeah
mating nets for a car to figure out but
he only has 30 seconds if you're da
brother and uh that's not good rook
check the King's running in I just 95
okay yep King D oh gosh King d7 who's
gonna get made it I think why does not
get made it's a king of seven rook c7
King e6 well oh you just gets the rooks
off the board heads for a draw uh-huh
so take harder knows he can draw now
what if a car somehow won this game
because I wouldn't be surprised that
Bishop c5 you know and everything's
falling apart yeah this is why you play
bad openings it's why you play the
villain akaru cuz you can if you if you
want you can also play the bloomenfeld
in chat you may get a lost position and
swindle your way to a draw - this is
ridiculous like Dobrev is fighting for
the draw now yes
running back hopefully hopefully
hopefully hopefully a new word hopefully
the act of hoping a3 go king d3 and we
should lose everything now draw he's
playing on Nietzsche yep play on yeah
for sure
oh man look at him look at him just
doing the Cora thing doing the card
thing taking some water I got all day 45
seconds he might answer the chat at some
point hey hey everybody how's it going
chat what kind of dumb bleep is Danny
saying now yep ha well if you're just
getting here let's remind everybody we
got a very busy week of the speech Chess
Championship a full a schedule full
slate ahead
obviously a car Nakamura throwing down
right now in case you have just somehow
got lost and didn't know where you were
on the internet that's what you're
watching but we've got mama JA reverses
so as Wesley said how did I get shocked
in the first round I think we're in for
a dogfight tomorrow can't wait and then
October 3rd it's a doubleheader worthy
of extra-inning baseball Roberts
favorite sport there's some great Schnee
blur schneller Hikaru loading his
Difference keep the great gesture yeah
the even the table base and divorce key
PDF tell you this one's a draw so this
is just a game of tickle da brav knows
that he wants to get bullet because
that's where Hikaru is even better than
in blitz that's a thing
you know to be Takara Nakamura you have
to play better and faster that's pretty
tough to do pretty tough to do because
you usually do one of the other yeah
but we've got a very very we've had it
we've had a lot of fun here still plenty
of chess ahead so who knows what we're
in for in bullet don't go in or will we
get a 10 and a 10 in a row a lot of
people hoping to see that I'm in bullet
where her car Nakamura does crazy things
so the bad openings continue for
Nakamura here but unfortunately for a
dub Robin hasn't made a difference yeah
I mean this sort of stuff is trying to
capitalize on the fact that blacks King
is in the center the bishop 1f8 has
nowhere to go for the time being and so
of course black sponsor looks great you
have six pawns from the dita h-file
but white is much more developed and
there's some back rank issues that if
you're not faith in my it and now you've
passed a and B pawns so a4 a5 before
things like this
oh no but it's good for black this is
good for black if you can get the King
out of the center well queen c8 followed
by Bishop before it doesn't look like
your Kings uh good point I'm not getting
my king out of the center without rook
takes b2 and after rookie taking on
eight what do you think with that I like
them apples oh he didn't like them
apples he said let me trade oh wait no
Queen if he gets the Queen's off you
know Queen b8 Queen b8 and I got nothing
cuz Queen b6 I'll take you on b6 go
Roque Jack and pulling fisherman
actually maybe you'll get out of this
somehow I thought I was just gonna
squeeze you where you go f6 king of
seven kind of stuff and I think still
think white is much much much better but
there's some chances
there's Queen b8 yep yeah this is super
tough Dobrev is uh I thought this was
good what happened to f6 I guess he and
play f6 here after after a six takes
there's there's no lines here where
black can just gobble
on I guess it's always dangerous but a
super risky felt like this is not the
best line for a closest iliyan for white
or sorry Ross a limo turned weirdness
kind of close to Sicilian structure but
uh but okay yeah I mean to acardo's
credit here it's become quite the mess
and f6 is gonna run the King out Hikaru
gives a face that he's not not an
approving of Darwin's idea there yeah I
mean interesting right now king f7 rook
e8 man get your Bishop out black gives
up a bond and even if you lose the d4
pawn that's not the most critical pawn
in the position for black yeah good boy
these B and D pawns are the Queen's were
trade those would be isolated pawns if
you could try to really take advantage
of and this be pawn is a passed pawn
technically it was very far away
it's a rook e8 here yeah rook e8 I've
been the rook now you can de move the
bishop
okay not anymore right now there's crazy
ideas like 'if I've to cut off the
bishops Oh Queen c1 threatens a draw
who actually five looks pretty good even
though King e6 ideas are rookie six huh
yeah actually if Queen b3 check you
would have had rookie six no but this is
not a bad idea either getting the
Queen's off the board who's better here
I mean I guess right after yeah you're
gonna try to come to e7 and he's gonna
lose he thought he had broke a seven I
think but yeah five yeah that's what
he's missing here comes e5 and if you
take you win a piece and Cara shakes his
head there yep now it's not the
shake-and-bake you liked it's not the
shake and bake a coral is accustomed to
giving us what he's happy and he goes
for the shake and fake or is that a is
that a Westbrook move shake and bake I
don't know I haven't officially
catalogued all of the names with like
giving a cards faces names only numbers
there I think that's good enough numbers
are good it's like we're talking last
night I like symphonies you know it's
like yeah number seven numbers because
it always makes you wonder how high that
number when numbers are right now okay
this is just this is just defaulted Caro
this is just fully focused and
like you know nothing no message is
being sent here just try to place yes
okay so I'll ask you again soon right
we'll get you we'll get to it oh that
one the I roll the I roasted oh yeah I
mean no a car number seven is it
genuinely frustrated not it's a that
there's the I role of looking up because
I'm thirteen moves deeper than you and
then there's the I role of what did i do
right totally different I roles alright
but you may end up getting a draw here
he's gonna have to grovel for this
because blacks up a pawn this is your
chance if you're dumb Brooke you've got
to push these kind of games yeah bring
they came back to e6 threatened rook b7
this is what you got to do and I don't
really know why you know he could have
brought skink forward instead of you
know the way he did this way but he's
gonna go over up b7 try to hit the pawn
if you go Brooke b5 saying I'm not gonna
let you get to my pawn there be rick a7
the rook would infiltrate so he's doing
it this way
and I run p7 yeah now you okay this move
is gonna oh this yet go for it because
you can take and then get the king in
front yep just in time Brooksie to
Burke's III o Ali Ali that's gonna be a
UH it's gonna be a victory for job
repair infection headquarters so
frustrated he just resigned throws in
the towel on that one
Wow you know pretty sure he wasn't
whispering sweet nothings there there
might have been a an explicit oftheir
but ya don't bro doing a car Nakamura
that was the opening theory check that's
a car number three opening Theory there
you go what's the cell Jochen yeah yeah
okay now hey Carla actually really likes
this opening for black unless regularly
plays it on chess comm so there you go
Wow well interesting interesting stuff
here we still have plenty of chess ahead
sixty minutes roughly total right now
with twenty five minutes and three
minute and then thirty minutes a bullet
lots to come so don't go anywhere
having a lot of fun do i shade ox
comment there roberts green screen is
much better than before it looks like
he's the preview of the power of
technology we actually have a hologram
right I feel like kylo Ren like we're
reaching through the void
what's the other girl's name ray you can
be right am i kylo Ren I would be the
bad guy can Ray Rob send me the Ray to
your Colorado that's right ray Robson
probably over there just spending lots
of time playing pause battles make a
good life decisions you know not that I
shouldn't promote people using our
premium features but Ray we need to have
a talk
yeah I mean who have spent so much time
solving puzzles yeah he loves it it's
it's it's it's amazing but it's just I
go in there and I and I worry about him
like gonna call his dad like hey Gary
you know when does Danny's book on him
Carl's face is coming out as Stephie 94
soon as I retire which may be sooner
than you think you know who know you
never know we've got we've got lots of
books ahead to write including they tell
all you know cheaters confess on chess
calm the car Nakamura faces things
behind the scenes with Robert that's the
book that I'm gonna write exactly what
it was like to deal with Danny we hired
an HR department for did to deal with
that all right interesting stuff
delbruck did just get a big win they're
only down by five and actually in
control of this one too yeah no he's
looking to be in good shape here and
right now
he has the queenside pressure he's got
to unravel the a pawn that's that's two
pastors yeah many teams you consider
pushing it ooh Bishop d6 coming in
coming exchanged when a car keys miss
Grubb miss Bishop d6 trapping the rook
how did here Carl get this one this was
I mean let's back this thing up while
they think about the live position just
so we know oh yeah that's right it
wasn't a yeoman's hell yeah hens oh yo
hands out yakkin it's so up for debate
it's a yo hen oh yeah conohan is like
the Russian L yakin is it depends on
things I need you see the Cyrillic there
I've had this conversation so many times
okay anyway but this opening is designed
to get black dubious positions and
that's kind of what happened to a car oh
this is just a good good Queen side
advantage lots of pressure to better
than one
in fact Delbert just wins this pawn
comes all the way back to h2 because the
queen is doing the job of guarding d4
okay a car was gonna mix this one up and
we've already seen him pull a few
rabbits out of the hat today so nice
Queen sounds I move this could be two
games in a row for dobro vacarros not
careful right yeah it would be exchange
of queens on the table here the d5 pawn
is weak that B and a pawns just rushing
down the board yep
so this looks like the b4 b5 b6 I think
you know where I'm going after that you
going all the way all the way right he
just he's in China over up b8 I guess of
a4 right away why she watch out for
Bishop h6 ah that would be a problem so
he's gonna go Corral Daryl when I work
c8 yep good move you can take though and
play Knight up one Bishop takes on b2 I
get d5 yeah but somehow seems a lot
better for black not giving he's gonna
go for it I mean yeah I agree I mean hey
Carlo has improved his drawing chances
but okay this is a great move
yeah you don't want to you don't want to
settle on Knight f1 you'd rather play
the position ah yeah but the rook b3 or
is getting counter play so Bishop f4
here is a way to protect d2 and also
threaten some Bishop h6 I claims that
idea right what do you know oh you know
nothing you know that's the first step
of knowing I know nothing in my case it
didn't work out it'll earn anything on
the other side I'm saying not to get too
philosophical but isn't knowing nothing
technically knowing something is noting
something existentialism Dobrev is not
happy right now yeah he shouldn't be
blue it yeah f2 s f2 is under pressure
he's down I'm almost emitted on the
clock and now the D pawn how did this
happen I don't know it was just a bad
position for black but I feel like he
does that to us a lot you know how did
love you Brosnan get his face on a mug
that I drink out of regularly I don't
know things happen we all make mistakes
everyone Guardium love here Osman the
Guardian levere Osman
okay well rook takes d5 should be should
be a peaceful result but black has a
little bit of irritating pressure
okay now king of one if you want to get
two phones lost yeah actually
okay okay so how did how to win this
game because of course Oh Bishop f4 now
15.5 pawn okay rook d7 with tempo and a
string King moves h4 you got a guard yep
but now that pawns cemented our rook F -
oh gosh
Kim okay rook d3 no but just you're out
of the Kings tell me that five don't
brothers frozen Xin let it go I saw the
trailer for frozen - coming out what
yeah I didn't know that yeah I'm said
about that it looks wait there's a cool
draw here okay so you're gonna
eventually go bring your keen to e4 it's
not it's not gonna happen but it's like
like Keegan now support oh yeah yeah you
know I'm gonna do yeah I didn't know it
I'm gonna show it check let's just get
the King there because I'll walk him
into the stalemate yeah still bit yeah
so this the the draw is you give up the
night but you sacrifice for stalemate
right here of course it car when King
III which is very smart right and it
doesn't allow it and double just resides
oh man that one hurts yeah that one
hurts hey Danny
yo can I can I give you a nice pun I
love it frozen to snow Keo drift cuz
this now
should I play the cricket sound it would
have worked it would have worked but let
me tell you Tokyo Drift is the one fast
and furious that we all wish we could
forget it's the mistake you know it's
it's the mistake I mean everyone has I
have four kids I won't say which one
right snake everywhere okay I mean uh
none of your kids are mistakes don't do
that yep no I didn't say I don't I
didn't say I have a favor they're all
the same but every once in a while
there's one kid that was unplanned I'm
not gonna be involved
Tokyo Drift was the unplanned kid of the
Fast and Furious franchise it's okay can
I talk about this okay there's a
conversation you need to have with your
wife welcome to chess calm everyone
we're the professional shows and
coverage of the world's biggest events
that happen online right here twitch.tv
slash chess hit the follow button go to
chess comm TV for the full schedule
Grand Master Robert Hess here all week
here all week hanging out with the fam
we've got a whole lot of events coming
up including the Fisher random World
Chess Championship quarterfinal this
weekend it's it's it's gonna be awesome
there are eight of the world's best
players throwing down in it including
one of them that's playing today a car
Nakamura so this is a you need to mark
your calendars of course after that the
Isle of Man Magnus Carlsen and Cara
Nakamura lots of controversy onigiri
dropping out we're gonna talk about that
at some point and they'll not happy
interesting stuff and then the fisherman
dome World Chess Championship final will
be in Norway I'll be there in Oslo and
it's gonna be fun so thank you alright
then what do we got here some kind of h6
g5 madness e o night o cuz the 98
strapped well I like it
that's nasty yeah what about nope I got
nothing I would say Oh Bishop a4
protects when you should go b5 yeah
there's nothing actually very nicely
played there by Dell bro then now again
if he wins this game he almost could
have won three in a row at this point
and obviously we know Hikaru is the you
know scoreboard right up six games but
he's played well today yeah I mean it
feels like he's played well he's been in
a lot of games and pressuring and you
know been swindled under time pressure
but he's he's done okay it's a very
respectable showing yep we should be for
maybe saves everybody kind of yeah we
just take on G wait what does black us
two minor pieces right now yeah but what
white has to Brooks right so busy Ford
that looks pretty good I agree with you
cuz you can't move the night without
giving up fish one of three so Bishop g4
is there something that I can do as a
response age sixty-five Bishop takes c2
looks yeah you're gonna get age six yeah
g6 and just saying two pieces for the
rook but okay and Carlos got the
potential of a lot of open files right
pick your flavor of squares and probably
why should be queen f5 here just keep
the initiative going yeah don't don't
settle on the pawn that's that's
irrelevant or queen bee five nice we'll
take it right yeah go for that be two
point very good move actually hit b2 you
want to improve the night maybe II for
what do you love things to try would
love to be able to play tonight at four
here obviously I can't because you just
take it
but somehow night F 492 stuff would be
great to have happen
yep okay so he took the pawn so now as a
rook in one pond for a night in a bishop
so by material it's you know interesting
situation by position I like the minor
pieces one the rooks but still a lot
left to prove okay 25 you want to get
rid of these tactics Oh King g8 also
just the trick in a way but I mean I
don't know I have a hard time believing
that White's gonna lose this one at all
yes especially now that White has
positioned his pieces so well mhm
move the Queen if you can simplify you
still have a rook in a pawn for the two
minors so mathematically we are equal
here okay
keeping the growth on the board this is
blacks best chance I mean f2 is hanging
right rook f1 I just want to be able to
do something nasty b6 just play it safe
then play 95 and play Bishop d3
you just like feel you can just somehow
make progress here oxy does it really
nasty at night c5 mm-hmm
and if you go Queen takes a seven yep
I'm gonna night d3 and my throws queen
takes up one check oh you didn't go for
it but I'm gonna show it 93 and if you
take again queen takes up one puzzle
rush actually I look pretty tough to
deal with yeah in fact how would he
you've dealt with 93 instead of taking I
have no idea I think you just totally
missed this because if you move the rook
f2 hangs yep this is actually a really
great find by Robert here and this is
instructive it's why you learn your
mating patterns because that's you'd
have to play g3 but if you played you
threw your light squares or 95 comes I'm
some 85 cut in here you can also back up
the lady and head to g4 yeah so yeah
interesting stuff now dump our probably
shouldn't lose this one even with that
being said but that might have been it's
only really but we have said that before
that's true that's true
many people have said famous last words
against a coral okay the rooks are not
coordinated well that's what you need
when you have to rush against minded
pieces to coordinate them but right now
those rooks are not each other's friends
got to be careful right the rook ever
leaves the back ranked rookie one so if
Vlad has taken advantage of that is he
gonna tickle this one out why why is it
going bishop c2 and now let's say bitter
and Zach are playing for a win here wow
that's a bit shocking right I mean he
couldn't just finish off the edition he
kind of knows that he's akaru but he
also knows that he can play for what
objectively his position is diamond
member jf boy or 5 to 7 says yeah time
pressure so maybe he's maybe he's
playing for time pressure for Dubrow da
Brooke Nicholas here comes rook has to
back up
92 if you take those rook e1 yep but
this feels own you can't Quincy if I was
Knight h3 check so you to figure out
where your Queen can go it's like a line
and hit this night yeah cuz the Queen is
guarding the third-ranked right now yeah
but rook b2 for example actually roof b2
is pretty interesting
rook we to main to being the move but
then rookie to it's just like a such a
mess
okay Queen c3 also allows rookie to but
no and there's no route because the
Queen can take yes you can play rookie -
oh we didn't see it
91 what Oh Queen c2 he is queen of 109
t-34 key mode get your Forks out don't
hurt anybody that was filthy he gets out
barely he's gonna play Bishop d3 but
okay only eight seconds still probably
best play is a draw for this position
but indeed laughs he smiles he smiles
where's the hammer you know remember
when Jeffries y'all gave us the lesson
that if you smile when bad things happen
it doesn't feel as bad cetera I haven't
I don't know I haven't tested it that's
kind of how it seemed right there feel
psychologically sound though yeah
another now we oh hey Siri when you
smile does that make you feel better I
don't hear anything
Siri just smiling make you feel better
what accent is that Australia of course
you like to rotate us accents cuz it's
just penny know about that I'm working
on the Isle yeah I don't Matt just
spending know about that yeah of course
he knows okay I'm sure yeah I tried to
get Penny's voice you're like I'll give
you a raise those who don't know our
director of media production mr. penny
work thank you for all that you do
anyway anyway anyway doesn't it feel
good to pay this this is a big blender
by Doh rough so he's an exchange yep
[Music]
guess the movers didn't have time for
that one no time to guess the move but
previously we had someone getting 12 out
of 38 not too bad I guess I mean you
know you just hit me with these we
didn't call them penny wise have you
seen it - of course not okay
you know I care about my emotional
well-being okay me too I want when you
have kids you can't watch movies where
kids die okay firstly spoilers we can't
you can't you can't ruin movies everyone
knows that it has been around forever I
mean you don't know what people know
yeah also why she literally slowed down
my wife and I watching stranger things
like we couldn't emotionally take it
okay
this is what happens in like a blowout
in baseball the commentators just start
talking about stuff yeah right now we've
got a eight game lead for a car Nakamura
and still 9,000 people who I think are
sticking around to see if you can make
it ten in a row
get those carts out get those chest
broad emotes out right how many
consecutive wins if like three and this
point I don't even know not many
yeah I mean double just one one a few
minutes ago but there's some problems on
the e-file here okay any means falling
though Oh some positions but they're
broken h5s hanging that's a problem
that's what evidence when you bring the
rook too far out you let you want to
back that thing up right now he saw that
so quickly the big dick after Queen f4
like the tray hits the Vulcan h5b two's
not hanging because all this what he
does that's a car oh yeah and Dover
listen to you yes it's a good thing it's
a good thing and oh okay but now you've
got the two knights solidly that back
rank is your only problem if you can fix
it protect it this is gonna be a better
engine for white your car just shook his
head he missed something
hmm maybe there was a trick was there
Brooke take C - what huh oh no what's
there no okay
if you take here there's some craziness
right but you can just take with the
night yeah okay so I don't know what he
was shaking his head about that I'm just
trying
translated : you see know how I usually
know usually well now that I've solved
that it wasn't chess know what it is we
need six hidden the undefended rook on
d2 Dabra of looking for a big victory
that's a nice move it also prepares to
bring the rook back and a car keys for
his Queen f4 he wants the ladies off the
board and him say g5 it makes yeah and
g5 it makes perfect sense to trade
Queens when you haven't like the night
against the bishop right ideally why
trades the Knights in e2 and e3 for each
other and then plays this night against
the bishop but you've said this many
times is always a good point that the 94
looks great it's just like on a square
that is a 30 but what is it really doing
right so yeah the issue is it might
still be a better end game for white if
all the majors came off just cuz
although maybe not actually I guess the
c4 pawn holds back b2 right there's
ideas like 91 he's actually thinking
about something a queen f4 95 stuff like
yeah go for the back rank mate decides
to keep the ladies on the board and the
biggest issue overall is making those
types of moves even if it proves to just
oh it doesn't the PCs work he won in the
end
oh recorders talking yourself he's
talking to himself why did I do
listen 95 was coming yikes
95 yeah don't rub with some good
tactical swindle swindle so if your head
car do you just spend the rest this time
play one game yourself oh no he just
resides yeah just a one move blunder
Dobrev his like that was like a like
strong like bull
he should have brought the hammer out
for that I've seen that face he what you
see a cars did look the openings no look
at the opening but bonk load yeah hey
Carl played the bond cloud he's gone
early with it get it out of the way
office to-do list in case it's a close
match and bullet and his fans want him
to play the bond cloud he's already done
it yeah you know priorities right
keeping the fans happen you can follow
hey car Nakamura at his channel
twitch.tv slash GM Hikaru yeah i'ma fall
I don't know but Vlad - bro is it just
glad - bro should I just say that was
what is flat dubrow's
I don't know if somebody must know
anyway so he's on twitch okay and he
caught him I just get hammered this one
it over wants to be him so bad for the
blonde cloud yep so uh he'll go like
full goth noise Tortuga chess not once
you place a ball and cloud of my
daughter's wedding
what was that but not once have you
asked come here for coffee tea Godfather
no I thought but it didn't really the
new team from Italy in the protest
League has asked if they can have their
name be the Italian Godfather's and
what'd you say how they we can't why not
because first of all is it like
copyrighted or something like that the
word Godfather I mean uh no obviously
not yet okay but yeah why not we should
let him do it
The Godfather versus umbrellas would be
it would be quite very pretty epic
alright well hey Carlo has two pieces
for the rook and he's just searching
around the room his eyes are just like
what to do now yep you could follow the
games live as said right there there's a
link and that you can play guess the
move a lot of people doing it on chess
calm that Queen might be running out of
squares here soon but take on C to get
greedy
yea-ah I want it what the pony wait
like us too two minor pieces for a rook
yeah I thought it was just an exchange
then boxes crushing I think it's whole
time was in the impression that it was I
was doing great here yeah for some
reason I was thinking that it was just
one piece for the rook that's two PS he
just won with the blonde cloud like it
was nothing at three minutes I don't
know what to say anymore so you know I
that's why you took a little swig there
its water
so that's so defensively this has not
been the best opening for black
although the cons stuff reminds me I
feel like when I played Dabra in Russia
it was a con like he's been playing the
con for a long yeah well I have to ask
him about it I'll ask him if he
remembers the game afterwards stick
around so if you were wondering for
reasons to stick around you're gonna
hear the other story of 15 year old
Danny wrench he was a young American
wild in Russia for a whole summer played
in a tournament against Vlad de bravas
he got his last GM norm I got my first I
am norm together we made history find
out what happened in that game in the
interviews afterwards and we'll see if
Dobrev remembers what he did to me he
can never take back did you involve the
hammer that he does just say I just left
everybody with a ton of teasers you did
and every one of them is gonna be
deliver this isn't lost like what
happened with the polar bear why was
there a polar bear on the island right
I'm not losting you right now I've only
answer every question I just dropped
take that JJ Abrams night at 4:00
you're very invested in that one right
move I put a lot of time and lost 1-0
time into it no time loss for me and get
it yeah well Who am I sitting next to
the worse I'm not seen next to the
godfather of dad puns that's right thank
you
okay let's talk about the tension here
if the bishops are traded the b6 pawn is
weak so black doesn't want to trade
because then b6 is the problem white
doesn't ever want to trade because the D
file opens up the d4 square is available
and the dark squares end up being things
you wish were safer so this is a classic
example where a lot of lower rate of
players would just not be able to build
on the tension but watch how these
players do it right they were both
trying to force the other to blink one
way that white could do that via a ton
of time right Robert would be like a
three move the knight and B four right
but it's hard to do that yeah one of the
you know you've made a great point that
if there's an exchange on c5 that gives
black firm control of the dark squares
but
turn exchange on III the b6 bomb which
is no longer there would have been an
issue so he said place for b5 quickly
saying night 8 takes e5 I've moved II
takes e5 and your queen on d2 is under
attack right and so tempo putting the
night in okay but look how he's also
just kind of laughed in the face of
danger over here the night hanging on
the for I love it
it's a dangerous mule name you know
else's middle name is danger no yes I
was so worried for a sec it was such an
obvious pop culture but scare me you you
you went silent on me I don't know I was
looking at diamond remember Ross FA in
the chest TV she I to answer he said the
Dharma Initiative was known for adopting
polar bear adapting polar bears get back
to you on that so 95 is coming yeah 95
tempo under on the bishop I mean again
like the Khan has I I don't like it for
black but he's he's played it
aggressively yeah he keeps trying with
it but it doesn't seem new working out
very well
now f6 like Queen age six would have how
but he resign
cuz the c5 was hanging that's pinned
just down Paul yeah the dark squares or
just so the f4 Knight Bluff just didn't
pay off he was like kind of left it
there I move too long g6 allowed him to
take instead of moving the night I mean
anything would have been better than
losing the piece for free Philly then I
got trapped there at least three times
today he's bad we'll see if we can make
it a baker's dozen up up before for
those nights that getting trapped angles
that's right bagels baker's dozen bears
Ditka bears bagels bears
[Music]
a Premium Membership at chess calm will
help you improve your game with full
access to a powerful set of learning
tools unlimited tactics let you practice
like a master with more than 50,000
puzzles to challenge you in every level
our library of interactive chess lessons
created by master coaches will enhance
every aspect of your game and after each
game you play the computer analysis
feature will give you feedback on every
move you played turning every game into
a chance to learn and that's not all
premium benefits also include unlimited
tournaments video lessons the opening
Explorer and much much more upgrade now
to take your game to the next level will
the light just go down the city come on
for dubrow VIN the bullet portion this
is the chest icon night light that a
friend made for me I don't have one
because you don't have friends like idea
ok will the light come on for dubrow Vaz
Grandmaster Wesley so just set in chest
comms chat he just has to go Tendo and
bullet not that hard will hurt by what
just happened but your app so you're
right that Dobrev needs to go in an
absolute terror against you know only
the best no it's too late I think it's
really cool though I figure the Joker
from the 90s Batman you're the Jim
Carrey Joker the Riddler excuse me
Riddler sorry I made a mistake Jack
Nicholson you know what I'm an I made a
mistake all right we got the bracket
here Hakkar Nakamura facing off against
Vladimir too bro if you're just getting
here thanks for being here don't go
anywhere we have the full bullet portion
up ahead gonna be exciting stuff as as
Grand Master Wesley so did just say that
wasn't made up on chest comm you can
hang out with Grand Master's over in the
chest home game chat he says uh Bob just
needs to go ten and no no big deal so
let's let's see if he can do it and both
players are back they are sitting they
are ready let's remind everybody that
right after this match and our
interviews of course the title Tuesday
will begin Geoff comms monthly event for
$1,500 in cash prizes we get a lot of
very very strong players I don't know if
a car was playing
dobro playing but there's gonna be a lot
of shrunk players so right after this
international master levy Rosman will be
hosting title Tuesday so with that I
think bullet is about to begin
no further IDU and here we go all right
and we're off
Vlad gets the wipies in the first game
and he's played quickly it's a good
start it's a good start you got to play
quickly in bullet I see someone just
talking about the Duda Nakamura match
that we're headed for at some point in
the bracket that could be amazing I
agree that will be amazing all right
we've got a row goes in kind of obscure
variation here camber Springs esque yep
and generally White's happy with the
pawn structure the pawn on b2 is now on
c3 a strong center but you're also
behind in some development and your
kings in the center so not eat 64 no but
okay with the Queen's coming off then
you know the center is not as effective
you have to be careful about it becoming
a target on the D file here comes the a
pawn under fire can't take it yet that
would lose a piece all right this is
this is playable for both sides I just
think that the long term and games often
favor black in these structures because
you have this Queen side majority and
Knight c3 now there are some tactical
ideas as well oh now 93 Bishop c4 is
coming yeah hit card no likey like been
told that he karo we believe is gonna be
playing in title Tuesday maybe even
streaming to his channel don't know that
you can go to twitch.tv /g Makara so if
you need more Hikaru it looks like he's
got his head bobbing going music a
Roland so uh hey Carl might be in a good
mood after this match yep that's a win
right there he now has attending game
lead and getting closer and closer to
our match prediction this is this is
what a karnaki more ducks right this is
why I mean if we want to bring up the
score progression and the odds to win
the match as far as why we see the the
heads heading the directions that they
do
hey Carter Nakamura is used to being on
top of other small tiny heads well you
do have the car Fathead somewhere here
well you know your tiny head
relative to the bighead yep
aren't you happy here Caro today yep
she's waiting for that moment
hey Robert hey car how's it going you
gonna play title Tuesday with me no I
probably won't okay well nevertheless
I'll be streaming at my channel ok well
how about a little baby a car it's you
know you don't know what's going on
because you're not looking oh I got and
now I'm unhappy that you're not playing
why aren't you playing well you know
you're making me sit through some
meetings so it's not really my fault
right we got some fish of random
planning meetings after this you got
work to do there's a very unhappy a car
filled a good talk everybody so I can't
go back to chess after that how much I
must have just talked about this
position where hikaru is now even in
material yeah o-5 what nice I mean he's
gonna take h5o cuz you still with the e
pawn there's ISA Queen e5 check oh that
was nasty just show it quickly boom zoom
that's a hanging rook and Hikaru doesn't
want even the h5 fine he wants to force
this tactic to happen you know dump rub
under time pressure finds Bishop b5 he
knows clock looks pretty good pretty
good right
rook h7 just be defensive c4 nice moves
Flitz the board keeps the Queen out of
the Kings side and that's gonna hurt
okay
I don't know I'm still trying to bring
the Queen back card did a little bit of
a head shake there something bothered
him I guess the fact that he can't get
to the f7 pawn because the Queen on D 2
saves the Foursquare and watch out watch
out for Bishop before and Bishop h6 and
then rook f7 okay I thought he had a
different meeting that idea of mine okay
now he's he's freed the g3 square for a
check followed by infiltration f5 is
almost always a really awesome defensive
move yeah not like f6f-5 yeah five
chocolate Down Goes the Queen on d1 work
g3 Queen digs d1 o e OE
that hurts jump rope not happy I don't
have I don't have a fat head of him just
hanging out in the office
with a hammer with a hammer yeah maybe
we'll make make an emote hey cars just
casually 32:55 and bullet yeah no big
deal no big deal
but anyway it's been a great match
honestly it's finished showing we kind
of expected Sakura Nakamura doing what
he doing what he does
yep we'll see if he can roll this
momentum into a title Tuesday victory
right after this as as we said if you're
just joining us leve Rosman will be
hosting commentary for the title tuesday
go down and anyway this is it gets tough
it gets tough in these positions right I
mean at this point we're hoping for some
exciting action well his best bullet
rating was 33 57
that's just absolutely out of this world
yeah 33:57 there's over a hundred points
higher than news right now right and
he's working it with a black piece in
this game to like look at that nine
eight to that night is not happy to be
there that night wants to be on c4 and
even then I'm not sure that white it
would be okay
alright they're not a happy camper has
anyone ever gone undefeated in a portion
of SCC yes for sure I don't I don't know
the the stats if our draws held against
undefeated meaning okay two questions
undefeated it's not losing perfect is
all right with I think I assume the
question went perfect but it definitely
is happening yeah undefeated has for
sure happen in portions whether someone
has ever been perfect we'd have to look
into that only victories in a given
portion I don't know neppo versus Danny
Leon is likely possibly yep alright so
in this one still no minor piece trades
and alright so you get the d4 square now
just take and plug I guess if you take
on that f2 first the e5 pawn was hanging
so he does this looking pretty promising
for
Cara he's just too good yeah a force
falling
yeah 90 43 is Oh even this take your
time can't stop it
can't stop won't stop open their me
Queen da Queen f6 very nice little
perpetual check right okay so queen a4
picks up the pawn tries to bring the
knight in to c3 you'll play Bishop c5
now yeah you can some nice tea and stop
nicely through the piece is gonna fall
yeah here comes nice III very difficult
Oh
taking his time look at that yep Knight
a3 gobbling the b-pawn that is technique
right there and you just have to move
forever you just keep that there's no
there's no fret for the case of G 1 G 1
H 2 yeah the upon anyway that was
amazing technique and again if you look
at the clock finding those accurate
moves without thinking about it it's
it's good to be king that's what a Cora
would say we got 8500 of you sticking
around I assume so that I can complete
the story of what happened between
Dobrev and wrench in Russia
we'll find out and obviously we'll
interview both the players when this is
done talked to Vacarro ask him who he
thinks his biggest challenger in the
bracket will be and dive into anything
else that comes our way if you got any
questions for the players throw them at
us you've got a chat in front of you
yeah we need we need to know what you
want to know and I'm sure for Hikaru his
next event is Island man coming up huh
to see if he can try to qualify for the
candidates the winner of that tournament
just the winner not two spots just one
qualifies for the candidate so of course
a car would love to win that and he is
an open tournament beast yep he's one
Gibraltar four times I want to say and
he just has been one to dominate open
events yeah well he has a very
enterprising style that creates the
chance for decisive results right and
when you're when you're a stronger
player than a lot of your opponents
which in the open pairing system happens
right you're playing down you know those
positions present
with the opportunity to outplay people
so you know I think that's why he's had
historically such good results he also
raised in the American circuit right
like me and you so he he knows how to
play a Swiss who knows how to play a
Swiss or - yeah he would Brian Boitano
do know did you turn it off
I'm Chevy talking while you're doing
this I feel like silence is required
perfect symmetry I don't want to follow
that up yeah you don't need you this
looks like a game that will be hard to
lose for black so aren't hard lose for
black maybe I'm wrong even Snow White I
thought I was gonna remain close but it
looks like a car was working his way in
it's no diggity okay several ways to
trying it ain't calculating things on e6
there's also Brooks e5 there's also f4
and f5 and he goes for it what's he see
another seven yeah
g5 he wants it he's just saying I'm
gonna sit in on position King can't move
d7 the Brooklyn of sevens hanging green
of fade there's Rick east six check for
the queen of oh I thought Queen of five
but now see six rookie seven check Oh Oh
everything's just he's got a lot of pods
for the rook so many he's got so many
boys
I mean Oh f7 he's got Queen e8 coming so
he's getting 58 in you know he's got
he's also got g6 coming
how many pawns you know why he resigned
you trade Queen I'll show it on the
analysis board real quick while the next
game starts the rook d8 the point is you
trade and then she's six and you have
two pastors first the brook and there's
notice that was that was freaking sick
that was nasty
why'd it take you so long to say that
took you so long to get there that was
absolutely that was just that was just
awesome yeah I mean he's just so good in
that sack I think look pretty good
anyway yep
especially for a bullet game just that
makes a arty arty man and chess mind
wives who've been consistent
guess the move players feel pretty good
about themselves get four out of five
it's only five guesses but you got four
out of five for a victory by a KO
Nakamura okay so we have some answers
there were two segments in the history
of the speeches champion that were
perfect meaning only victories not even
a draw a car Nakamura is three minute
portion versus Hoey fawn was perfect
only victories for a car oh and then the
pom knee oh she's five minute portion
verse and one minute verses Danielle Yin
well I didn't remember the bullet as
well but yeah dang that was uh that was
a tough matchup yeah there you go
those are the answers to those who've
wondered title Tuesday is coming up
right after this if you're here
wondering when it starts will begin
right after this I see a question for
Carl what music is he listening to okay
obviously what of course I mean yes as
long as it's not the Baha men everyone
are happy oh I'd be happy with some Baha
men I just want to answer the question
that everyone's been asking would you
please focus on the chest that's the
question that wasn't asking it's all
happening so fast right yeah it's like a
candy Chesney song don't blink you just
might miss checkmate honey - like I just
did brutal oh man the caro-kann you know
it's continued to play it yep
shouldn't work with it and these kind of
care constructors I play with white for
many years you have the two bishops but
look how solid blacks position is look
at the beset the triangle b7 to d5 to f7
it means there's light square bishop
well okay now it's no longer triangle
but the bishop on g2 has a hard time
breaking free right and very solid for
black but again this is bullet this is
uh King side attacks h5s coming who
knows f v h6 we should have been a new
variant where at some point in the
middle of a hikaru game I get to make
three moves in a row see how good he is
then
probably not that good when you just
take his queen off the board
no like I would try to play good chess
maybe get through is really the best
thing to just checkmater tape the Queen
no I mean I play for her car oh oh sorry
three of his I thought you were saying
that when you're playing a car oh good I
get two yeah yeah this is this is
getting brutal yes where are we at now
in the Tenno counter we haven't had a
draw in Bullitt I don't think right now
it's five nothing five nothing yeah
scores right before me X might be six
nothing with that game yep six nothing
six nil tough cuz da world is really
good yep I got plays in arena kings all
the times I was one of the top finishers
he won the the qualifier for this event
right he didn't get invited
he qualified his way into this SEC and
well he just happened to face pretty
tough opponent ooh Cara Nakamura yep a
consecutive wins right now but 1000 in
Bullitt would be required if we're
looking for the official term of
adoption for those of you who don't
speak twitch s pop culture it's a term
that's used to describe the process of
winning ten games in a row in a given
time control there is still a show
coming called adopted Danny we don't
have an exact date yet because Mexican
version of The Grove had a fantastic
World Cup when it is still playing he's
still playing in the the consolation
match right for third and fourth place
Conti Mon Sisk so I had to reschedule
ourselves the premiere of adopted Danny
but that show will come we'll get we'll
get a lot of people on it we'll give the
car a shot at some point I'm sure he'll
love it there is there are cash prizes
if they are able to win ten in a row
against me in a time control it's gonna
be fun - frozen cash price Lemann mats
are able to give you a shot in that -
but ya know you mentioned dobro I mean
he's super strong obviously this is a
tough this is a tough matchup he knew it
coming in right there are plenty of
events where the guys can stream and
play and Dobrev has a channel he often
it often they will they will stream and
play themselves play for themselves
while doing commentary in events like
arena kings title Tuesday glad to brov
right there
dobro Nikhil OSH OSH Nicholas Carr
shakes his head because he missed Queen
d6 check I think but he's still on the
grind here yeah right now what oh wait
why need to take on c7 first that was
very confusing did you see that yeah it
looks like he's about to get a victory
he could have enough a rook and now he's
gone and so going to win the game oh
yeah we just up a rook I mean okay still
has rook e8 check yeah coming this also
oh this wins force tonight back rook e8
wants the adoption though don't kid
yourself he may instead of even saving a
draw he's going to he's trying to win
with Nicene one check yeah he never was
gonna okay its mate though Queen d7
okay well Dobrev yeah he says no soup
for you no no ninth victory in a row if
you're counting to carry over from
three-minute no no 10 Oh victory will
happen here in bullet I'm guessing 13
minutes is not enough time to rattle off
10 more wins
so with that somebody just lost money in
Vegas don't know who it was
wasn't me I don't believe in gambling so
you know unless it's on my own chess
games seed overs blunder rook like full
rook you missed it I didn't butter stop
and look around every once in a while
yeah you miss it yeah so right now a car
up a rook in this game g6 is hanging
after that g7 is a mating attack that's
yeah just resigned I was gonna say I
don't even know why it would play it on
just to play I would say Grandmaster to
be good
which I guess the move performance oh
yeah whoa yeah maybe he will be a
grandmaster someday maybe already is a
grandmaster a secret account I could
look into his IP right now just kidding
we can't just do that for people
Grandmaster to be got 21 at a 33 solid
the silence is killing me just I need
you to talk I can't believe I'm saying
that out loud maybe Konami said that I
need it I need a break I need a break
invest it to be he's gonna meet me 21 at
a 33 gets the move I've seen worse I
haven't guessed 21 33 of my own moves
you are a superstar Hollywood treasure
all right Debra uh trying to hold the
endgame
should be a draw no shouldn't the car
was gonna give you five and one yeah
I'll pawn that night before if you take
on any six maybe night before if you
even if you don't take on a six
surprised you went this way because now
he's gonna lose a psyche that I think
just keeping the night there and playing
g5e for was actually better for a car
yeah okay this will also work as now the
night will have plenty of time to
outmaneuver the bishop with pawns on one
side of the board the night is a much
better minor piece in the bishop yeah
and there's so many different options
here he's six g5 try to play from punch
a four and I'd have three ideas you were
threatening to separate the pawns so
dope of trades but here comes the Knight
to e5 you can okay does that improve
drawing chances I guess it does get the
rooks off the board
why did you see that stat the record for
most points in one minute segment is 12
and a half
Karlsson verso 2017 Wow Magnus Carlsen
owns the one minute the most points in a
one-minute segment record what's a car
one pace to do right now he's got seven
if someone can tell him of the record
maybe he'll go for it well let's see
it's ten minutes left and not enough
time could be there's been some quick
victories in the match it's true he
needs to just take the draw in this one
maybe though
or maybe just ink a bunch of quick draws
haha way to work the system right yeah
okay just keep the King back now he'll
get f4 or or e3 that's amore yep guard
of five
yeah there's no way to make progress
without a blunder from white yeah it
looks like just gonna be repeating a lot
how could you possibly win this yeah
I'll just keep playing
I'll go III at some point but it's just
the draw yeah nine and a half minutes
left on the total clock will be joined
by these players asked of course the big
questions like what music is a car
listening to find out what happened
between Danny and dobro dobro ecolodge
in Russia
mm to its rings I haven't seen anyone
understand the Negro's reverence nobody
in chat is uh there were a couple
earlier they did okay I just missed it
all I need is one person to laugh at my
joke all you need is love nope just
someone to laugh at my jokes okay isn't
that love Wow on believable no now it's
two extra pawns and there they go oh
this takes hu pre-move much time acara's
he's a minute in 15 16 seconds wait is
that a record for most amount of time
when
it's not whispering me it's so creepy
you're right next to me talk to me like
I'm here
be present Danny okay master to be only
through down four guesses but was four
four four I'm gonna find out who Grand
Master to be is they or not
oh he's that's maybe why he's playing
guess the move of this old move so at
least he's gonna win something today
it's easier to guess your own moves you
know we do you have a fake account oh
man that is funny all right well this is
about to get surgical in the dark
squares yeah and white squares this is
gonna be this is gonna be painful
g6e 65s hanging the king's son he ate
love there's ugly double F pawns Black's
not even up a pawn for ya there's no
compensation right like it'll be great
because of all the matches were having
let's remind everybody real quick of the
schedule this week this is this is gonna
be the biggest blowout and so this is a
it's a good mood setter gets everyone
relaxes a little bit right let your hair
down get your hair did for the rest of
the week because I think every single
one of the matches coming up is gonna be
a lot closer than this starting with
mama Garvin so I I legit have no idea
who's gonna win that I'm gonna pick
Wesley based on SCC experience shock did
not have a great performance last year
against a nice giri maybe that'll
motivated motivated maybe that'll
motivate him yeah and then this one I
know LaVon vs. firoozeh you said that
LaVon in your eyes of the favorite
smarter chess agrees and I would say
they he's probably a slight favorite but
I mean alley race is just so strong and
just getting better and you know his
bullet skills yeah I think if all the
rezident than a couple games heading
into bullet then that's uh that's his
match he gets so and then you've got the
Russian on Russian action Artemyev
versus grish ik gonna be a blast for
that one I think that's gonna be a very
exciting match we have three great night
yeah I can't wait so much fun
almost as much fun as dobro this having
here in this match versus a car right
now that's the opposite of which
although I do want him to show us the
hammer again because that was awesome
and what's going on in this game he is
down to very pass pawns
they are very passed and they look good
on the six ring right looking good there
Stephie 94 in the chest TV chat more
information coming out about the protest
League this year been a lot going on
with that working hard to do everything
we can to make the best league possible
for the future so because of that we
haven't even wanted to announce the
qualifier because rethinking some stuff
has led us to rethink other things right
so I got to kind of start at the top and
so announcements will be made very
shortly about what we'll call the new
pro chess league as well as the
information on the qualifier and who's
gonna be trying to get in as far as
commentary goes I think I'll be here it
will definitely not be mr. Hess because
he will be playing in the Isle of Man
unless we wait till after that man we
probably will so maybe I mean you're not
gonna be here but you could be my coast
it sounds good
you're supposed to say BS you can be
mine no I wouldn't I would never do that
to you though I would never say that
yeah because you're nice man you're
polite you know you're so nice to me
even though I'm not always nice to you
you like your dad and onions you know he
loves onions onions don't always love
him that was a story I told you
confidence you can't talk about my good
you are my you're one of my besties than
you know that I love a lot of people
like wonder about our relationship
sometime yeah because you make a lot of
jokes I just sit here in silence like
does he really hate Danny yeah anyway
but we got interviews coming out then
we've got the title Tuesday so all 8,500
of you that are still with us don't go
anywhere should be fun
tomorrow is uh karu is Rowan he's
rolling um hehe if you missed the
opening real quick it wasn't a full bong
cloud but pretty close to it
ridiculous Grand Master to be 12 out of
28 the last one he'll be by coach you
need
[Laughter]
this is the joke yeah I didn't want you
to be upset about that wait how many
exchanges is black out right now - good
enough
I couldn't let your question and there
actually is some weird compensation
though here right black king is it's
gonna try to get the ladies off the
board to make sure he doesn't get made
it Eddie the Eagles got a future but how
fast can he run
not fast enough yeah gonna try though
actually this is just so simple right
King comes to G 397 well we got six
check is coming at some point yeah or
just get the Queen now and then four
come you know this should be seven your
idea was look rough III check was almost
made but you could block with it on the
III square
oh okay so make auto parts with the rook
yeah but he's but baton upon this is
this f6 square is key yeah but then you
go King mu and then Bishop g7 just
offered the exchange of Bishop I think
need to go Bishop yes bad yeah because
the rest of Bishop e6 in the 95 that was
a trick that Dobrev Hadley Horace saw it
what do you wait Bishop e6 check there
one the a to ponder oh wow why'd he do
it he won that's a great question that
what huh huh I mean it's gonna be a draw
now but wasn't Bishop e6 check looks
right what's he doing with his clock
he's smiling move Grandmaster move
always blunted his Bishop I mean he
doing he's laughing wasn't Bishop e6
check for gonna be - yeah it looked like
it okay
now I can't tell him Doros laughing as
in Windows or at us yeah or himself
really is he laughing with himself or at
himself Yeah right
I just don't know he's playing it out to
mate to try to get as much time off the
clock a good strategy
oh you're French how is the first French
van now
oh no we've had a couple of it we just
haven't been an anti French mode today
me and you yeah we've been nice no I've
just you know been distracted yeah the
first time sitting next to that user
named Horace Slughorn 9 out of 18 was
pretty Harry Potter reference yeah but a
Scottish flag I think yeah or a slug for
the slow court from Scotland oh geez six
square and a c6 square I've seen better
situations in my life he's even taken on
e6 he just puts the other night their
patients patient to virtual Garo
outperformed his own smarter chef's
predictions today not his own prediction
but are smarter chess prediction and
although it's partly because they played
more games than we thought I mean the
actual total score difference Dobrev
scored more points than we said he would
tradition but they played a lot more
game yeah so you see this question kendo
Rove win 19 games in a minute I believe
I believe I believe we all stand up I
believe I'll stand up but you stand up
you say I believe everyone goes I
believe you know just because you want
me to do it you're not gonna do exactly
I know that that is the very essence of
our relationship I know it really is
like an odd couple I keep ruining the
tape here Oren gets mad at me when I do
that I'm sorry I'm messing with the tape
under the desk don't you get any ideas
oh man this show can't end fast enough
I'm just hungry I was thinking this for
a while yep and we should before then
Brooke b3 then a3 at the end here comes
how did they do it they divorced when I
was six weeks old blunder whoa
blubbering PhD that's how they did it
and I got way too real how did they put
up with me he wanted to know I saw how
are we how are we gonna deal with the
interviews you're gonna find out
in just a few moments when we get back
Hikaru Nakamura Vladimir Dobrev joining
us don't go anywhere
speeches championship when we return
[Music]
are now joined by the players here after
today's speech has championship match
Nakara Nakamura wins by a final score of
27 to 8 but the big question to start
here for Vlad do you remember what you
did to me in Russia 2002 hello everybody
yeah hello I want to do to say good
games she got very nice my trade that
much nobody wants to be to be a mouse
long ago you won this game I'm sure I
have this game was confusing you with
Rio I did beat you what a Karl believes
is true right dude I was right you in
that game really funny is Danny was
telling me for the last three days you
you beat him I said he didn't bring this
up to make you feel bad humor really
thought I was my game with Bob Rio we
played in that in the Chess Club in
Moscow and you but I beat you anyway
Hikaru you look like you've lost by a
score of twenty seven to eight how happy
are you with your performance today
I mean I'm relatively happy with my
performance I mean I thought both my on
my opponent Dobrev played quite well and
five plus one and I wasn't serious
enough I think but then then I saw this
little like hammer clip and this
actually made me kind of annoyed so I
decided like no more fooling around in
the minutes three plus one and
when I really brought hi all right tried
to bring my best game I don't think I
played great but it was so good enough
so relatively happy well you you played
great and honestly I don't roam I think
you I think Vlad I think you got out the
hammer because you wanted to smash your
own computer right was that the case it
was so my well we were digging you could
have like how to had a broken-down
computer next to you and kind of taking
out your rage on a different computer
maybe next time but a lot of people in
the chat obviously we look at this
matchup today you played fantastic you
are the defending champion and the one
seed as we look at the the bracket a lot
of people wonder who do you see it
there's there's a lot of exciting
matches this week we've got obviously
critic and artemiev or throwing down so
in mama dr play tomorrow and then you've
got Aronian in firoozeh right i mean if
you don't mind I'd love for you to play
commentator and give us your thoughts on
those matches and who do you see as
maybe the the most dangerous potential
challenger for you to this year well I
mean first of all I think have a very
tough match coming up in the next round
if I'm not mistaken
again I'm playing do da I think yes yeah
so I'm kind of more focused on that than
anything else but I mean I think Wesley
is the clear favorite over Chakradhar
for sure I expect him to win that match
free cleanly based on the fact that
chakra is probably not as strong but
also he doesn't play play that much
online so I think Wes is a clear
favorite in terms of the other two
matches I mean it's it's hard I'm I'm
gonna to go out on a limb and say that
ali reza is gonna beat LaVon and not
match I think it's gonna be very close
but I think based on the fact that Ali
Russ is significantly better at 1+1 and
I think he's very good at learning from
from the matches he played in the Junior
speed chess championship
I think it'll pay dividends and I think
he's gonna find a way to win that match
in terms of the other one that's uh it's
what our tell me up against Chris Chuck
I think on very tough match to predict
uh I think that's close to 5050 I I want
to pull for uh for vladislav but I have
a feeling that Sasha's gonna be very
well prepared like he was in
previous previous versions of speed
chess championship I remember II played
a match against Maxime where he was
super well prepared so I think he's
gonna be very serious about it and I
think he's gonna eat he get out so I
would pick Sasha to win that match
fantastic analysis and you said yourself
at you and I did commentary together for
the juniors speeches championship final
and we talked about peruggia's obviously
lost away ye right in that event but
that experience really paying off you
feel like if he can if he can keep it
within range against Aronian do you see
him as a clear favorite and bullet yeah
I think he's got it he's got very good
chances and you know to me to make a
reference point to use a reference point
actually you know sort of pivoting back
one thing I was gonna say is I feel like
my opponent from the next round is
extremely talented young Christophe dude
all but one thing he's been very bad at
doing I feel is learning from his
experiences from playing matches
specifically for example he played this
match against Wesley in Moscow where he
won the first game them played a dragon
for absolutely no reason whatsoever and
lost that he played he played the match
against me in st. Louis and kept it very
close I did win in the end but then in
honty he did the same thing against
Jeffrey where I think he won the first
game two times and he couldn't hold was
black and and so I feel like he's not as
good at holding or not holding but as
learning from the situations with
playing matches in the same way that I
feel that ali reza is so that's why i
like with ollie res i think he's got
very good chances against the Hawks i
think he's very young and you look he he
internalized a lot of these these things
better and make sense yeah great
insights glad we know that Hikaru is
about to start streaming everyone can go
to twitch.tv slash geumja card he'll be
playing the title Tuesday are you gonna
stay up late and play the title Tuesday
with a carro here in a little bit yes
why not right 20 minutes we'll see them
so I anyway I want to apologize for
bringing up the game in Russia but
anyway you had it you had a obviously a
great match getting here you're uh you
know you were facing off against the guy
that nobody wants to play in this format
he car Nakamura
Wesley so in the game Chad said how did
I get paired with Mahmoud yaar of
nobody wants to play her car right so
you did great that look there were some
very very exciting games and I know
thank you thank you for the match yeah
thank you very much and mr. hope all
right big glad thank you well we'll chat
on slack hit me up see you bye Hikaru
good luck in title Tuesday see you guys
bye
well there you have it we see the
bracket updated with a car Nakamura
victory over Vlad - Bravo very one-sided
affair but you heard from your car
himself he's nervous is not the right
word but he is very respectful of his
upcoming opponent young Kristoff Duda
saying you know he's very very strong he
needs to learn from his mistakes is I
think it's words of wisdom from somebody
who's taking many many speed chess
matches and will be very exciting to see
that next round match-up between
Nakamura and Duda yeah I mean the next
round matchups across the board game Li
Ren de pomme neo zeon Wow
right and and of course this week is
about to to fill out the right side of
the bracket I I this is it's a it's an
exciting year right obviously everyone
looks at a car Nakamura as the favor for
many reasons but there's so many
heavyweights in the in the field this
year I think the karo knows that you
know he's got to be on Form make our was
a beast today fantastic chefs was played
and I think I think Dobrev also played
well I mean honestly I think it's just
hard to play a car in this format let's
bring up the schedule one more time
remind everybody starting tomorrow at
9:00 a.m. Pacific yet again we have mom
at Yarra and so throwing down Wesley was
hanging out on chess calm today trying
to warm himself up getting away from the
bughouse trying to play some real chest
we've got Aronian and Purusha and then
our team even grishnak you and i dude
busy week together are you ready
lots of speed Chess Championship lots of
fun I'm definitely ready and we had the
first exciting matchup just three more
matchups to come in two day period I'm
looking forward to it yeah can't wait on
behalf of everybody here at chess calm
we thank you those viewers that have
been here all day your your extra
special even if you just got here like
30 seconds ago like thanks for being
here as well but seriously everyone who
tuned in and has been here supporting
the show we appreciate it with you these
things are possible stick around watch
international mess
levy Rosman his commentary entitle
Tuesday and we will see you bright and
early tomorrow again at 9:00 a.m.
Pacific for the next speech Chess
Championship match peace out everybody